I would go and try to take everybody in
the world's money There Will Be Blood
Sweat and violence to get there because
if you don't the other Warlords will
knock you off if you swim with the
sharks don't be surprised if you get bit
everybody talks about body count and
this and that I think they're counting
the wrong thing I think it's what do you
think the benefits are of being
anonymous like that should are we
started sure benefits of being anonymous
well after hired berating my brand for a
couple years I've tested um you want to
be a prince not a king
in terms of being anonymous so the king
is like everybody knows him a peasant is
lost in the crowd nobody knows a prince
is good so what's the benefits of being
in the peasant crowd number one you
don't have people breaking into your
house going to prison I've had that a
few times fans break in had a guy try to
steal all my cars get seven counts of
Grand Theft Larson or Grand Theft Auto
um there's no way you'd be able to even
get away with that though because it was
all like orange exotic Lamborghinis red
Ferrar last no I used to have a Place
San Diego and La took a helicopter back
and forth till till I got freaked out
once on a helicopter I'm like that's the
last time I went on a helicopter those
things are too dangerous so I'm down in
San Diego in La
Hoya and I get a call 3: in the morning
I usually have my phone on I pick it up
Beverly Hills address hi this is Beverly
Hills Police Department we have a
strange question for you do you have a
business partner that you gave
authorization to take your
cars I'm like I don't have a business
partner like that's what we thought hang
up 5 minutes later okay the guy changed
his story did you do a Snapchat
contest that the first person who can
break into your house and take a car
you'll give him like an award for
Ingenuity and creativity I was like what
do you think what happened he's like all
right we got a guy here it was all on
camera this guy I and I had security
with a dude with a machine gun for two
years 20 grand a month 25 Grand a month
for a guy with a machine gun yeah he
would I used to to do gun of the day on
my Snapchat I thought it was a good way
to scare people off and it was kind of
fun so people were that invasive oh dude
like it was a big problem so I had a
house in Beverly Hills the address got
out early like people figured you could
just Google Ty house so it this was
Rexford right Rexford it had a I was
there for from you know 15 to 19 no you
didn't I did yes so you would okay so I
typed into well here's I was in real
estate and so I knew the house that you
were renting at the time you could look
it up the MLS one time I showed up and I
rang the gate and no one picked up and
that was it I wasn't expecting anything
I just thought like oh it's kind of fun
let's ring the gate is this when I was
there this is when you were there yeah
the second time uh we just happened to
be driving by cuz some people were from
out of town and I wanted to show them
like oh Ty Lopez lives here and your
gate was open with all the cars okay and
so we stopped and they were like taking
pictures and you were not there but we
we weren't going to do anything but we
just saw the cars come out what are you
doing here but but yeah this so This
dude so I'm in San Diego I'm like no I
didn't do a S Snapchat contest to break
into my house so it turned out we got
all the footage cuz I had cameras he
timed it cuz I had German Shepherds and
this it was a South African equivalent
of a Navy SEAL this guy it was a big
1acre place so he waited to his back
jumped over got in the side door went
into my kitchen 30 minutes on camera he
made sandwiches for himself packed a
cooler packed almonds nuts water all
this sh he knew where my keys were I
don't know how he he kind of looked
around eventually I started locking up
my keys but then he went out in the
garage tried to turn on a Lambo
Aventador it's a little bit hard to turn
on if you don't know how to do it
couldn't figure it out switches over I
had two rolls two lamos a Ferrari and a
Maserati couldn't get any of them except
the moer stupid Maserati I hate Maserati
he figured out how to turn it on put all
that stuff in the
trunk backed up but couldn't figure out
the gate there was there was a garage
door and then a gate and so my my
brother would house sit two of my
brothers and they were there with their
girlfriends asleep upstairs it's a big
house had 17 bedrooms and of course my
brother's supposed to be protecting the
place don't hear the girlfriend Joselyn
wakes up it's like somebody's down in
the garage and it's a good thing she
didn't go down cuz this was a huge white
guy it was a big redneck and he had come
like four times in the last month and
scared her at the door like I I want to
meet Tai I want to talk to him about
business and stuff so she just looked
out the window and saw him pulling out
and she called I lived that Rexford
streets on The Beverly Hills Police
Department same street yeah they came
like 15 cops jumped held him at gunpoint
and he started telling stories like no
I'm Tai's business partner first and
Jon's like no it's not and he like oh no
it was a contest on Snapchat yeah that
dude went to prison but he got out like
a month later because of overcrowding
like California doesn't hold people I'm
like calling Beverly Hills I'm like this
dude's gonna come back like well you can
get a restraining order like
California's but anyway so benefits of
when I was just part of the crowd and
people didn't know me it's just like you
live normal life there's a lot of good
stuff about it man you know like
Shakespeare said heavy hangs the head
that wears the crown I see all these
people it's like I've been the most
Googled person I like a month I was like
the most Googled person in the world I'm
like n I'm glad I don't have that
anymore so what is the difference
between a prince and a king from that
where does a prince cut off before then
you're a king I had somebody yesterday I
did that seminar you spoke at thanks for
speaking I and somebody's said you know
what was the happiest you ever were TI I
I'm like I think 2013 cuz 2013 I was
kind of a local celebrity in Hollywood
cuz I've been doing parties I did House
Parties I wasn't really globally known
and I just built a Instagram in 20 I got
on it pretty early so 2013 I was making
seven figures not eight figures with
with decent net margins okay so I had
money I had a little place but it was
cool did you ever come to my place up in
the Hollywood Hills no it was a badass
cool house it wasn't huge it was
probably like 6,000 square fet but it
had a view like I could see the ghetto
where I was born I could see from
Hollywood to Long Beach is 35 miles on a
clear day and it had a pool infinity
pool and it was like and I had you know
I had the lambo and Ferrari and stuff
like that but I was still and I was like
I said I was probably netting I don't
know what I was netting but let's say
500 Grand to a mill or something like
that so you had all the money you needed
um I didn't have that much
responsibility I had like six people
that worked in the house for me it's
making money online like I always had
and I would wake up and I decided I was
going to build my personal brand and I
would read three book I would read you
know people gave me a hard time like no
way Tyler reads a book a day dude I
would lay out three books on the bed
this better to me my brother is like T
you need to do iOS I'm like dude I've
already done the Mind trips I've already
done the LSD but like my version of it
you take three insane books and you read
them all at the same time I'd read like
20 minutes a one it's like so you switch
from like voler like a philosopher you
switch to like a business book like
Peter Ducker and then you switch to like
I don't know history or something and I
would do that and I would summarize
books I had built my book brand by just
taking 10 friends C seeing on a Gmail
and say every day I'm going to send you
a book summary I would write them it
take me like 3 hours to read the books I
would like really speed read it's you
get tired it's like a big deal you have
to like it's almost like going to the
brain gym I like myself up i' do like
two hours I'd read them I'd read most of
them um it depends if it was a huge
textbook I couldn't finish it but then I
would summarize it send it out and then
I have my other online businesses and
then at night I would go out have fun
dating life friends all my friends have
moved out from North Carolina that
was the life I remember I call this the
wakeup tap dance uh test Warren Buffett
says somebody asked are you happy he's
like man I'm 93 and I tap down out of
bed to the office every day my office
was in the same house I'd wake I
remember I can just vividly remember the
room I used to change which one was my
master bedroom I remember what year it
was CU of the master bedroom and I was
just like everything's perfect in my
life I feel like I was like Ah that's
the best and then from there that brand
started to grow and went from local
brand to all of a sudden it's like the
whole world new and then it only takes a
matter of months to starts to
happen like people talk about you
you're always like what you like what is
going on and so men are basically
driven schopenhauer the philosophers in
men are driven by three things food sex
and boredom but but I think it was wrong
I think men are driven by Envy too so
the second you're on the rise past
people will they don't feel threatened
by a prince you know like Oh I'm a
little prince of Hollywood right people
knew me I could go in any club making
money but I wasn't a threat to dudes
that saw themselves as a king the second
you become a potential King then all the
current Kings try to knock you down Dr
bus my evolutionary psychologist Mentor
calls that
derogation of competitors so it's all of
a son it's like a Blog about you like a
T it's a green screen no it's it's
all fake so all of a sudden like
Shakespeare said heavy hangings the head
that wears the crown they don't really
want to wear the crown is it worth it
then to limit yourself in terms of
potential not to be a king or can you be
a king disguised as a prince yeah sure
you can but you're a smart guy that's
probably if you're hyper ambitious you
want to be a king disguised as a prince
but the word will get out that you're a
king and the four drivers of humans
especially males will kick in especially
the fourth of envy people will Envy you
but before we go on to that we got to
thank today sponsor Shopify in every
business there comes a time where the
problem you've been ignoring needs to be
handled Jack did you pay your taxes yet
no still yeah you going to do it no if
you're getting frustrated with how
you're selling whether that be online or
in person I can't recommend Shopify
enough Shopify is an e-commerce platform
that's already transformed millions of
businesses worldwide including my own
bankroll coffee where we've been using
Shopify for years and before I actually
worked with graham I ran a few online
stores on Shopify and I was super happy
with it you're able to completely
customize your online store with
flexible templates powerful tools and
with a single dashboard you can manage
orders shipping and payments from
anywhere in the world what I find
absolutely insane about Shopify is their
ability to convert browsers into buyers
with the internet's best converting
checkout Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the US supporting Brands
like Alberts rothy and Brooklyn and in
over 170 countries plus they have an
incredible support team to help guide
you through any step along the way so
sign up for their $1 per month trial
period at shopify.com
guys there is not a better time than now
to start your online business again
that's shopify.com /ic to take your
business to the next level shopify.com
link is down below and now with that
said let's get back to the podcast what
are the downsides of being a king I know
you talked about people trying to steal
cars I'm sure that's the extreme but for
most people is it just criticism
criticism I mean first time I remember
moving to Beverly Hills making money
money now and get a maid service a big
house you know that house was 17 18,000
sare ft so you get a maid service they
send Maids there and you test out
different ones and I was like this maid
seems pretty good then you get a lawsuit
from her on her first day that she
tripped on a banana peel no joke tripped
on a banana she couldn't come with
something more original like this lady
watched Looney Tunes bug bunny I
remember Anvil fell on her
head
coyote yeah but I it was real literally
cuz we had this the garbage cans in the
back she's like I went around take the
garbage out and I slipped there with
banana peels it said banana pels in the
that was a frivolous lawsuit so it goes
away but I mean I never had that kind of
stuff happen when I was a prince I
remember Mr Beast came to visit me in
2020 he's like Ty you're a big
inspiration of mine I've always want to
meet you so he comes up when I was
living in New
York and he's like you know it's weird I
look at your net worth he's like it says
5 million online he's like that's your
real net worth I'm like that that's the
King descri desguised as a prince you
want that F tell dudes 5 million you
want a permanent 5 million googleable
net worth because at 5 million it shows
you know you're above average you make
some money you can provide if you're
looking for a longterm mate guys will
respect you but you're not a Target
lawyers aren't going to go oh you slept
with that dude woman put some pressure
on them if if that shows $50
million lawyers work on contingency
they're like well 50 million I could
squeeze 5 million out of them I'll get
half of it lawyers take 50 60% so all of
a sudden look at every man who is at
current King status you know some people
are like oh you fell off I'm like I fell
off at purp on purpose bro I'll let you
be the king now watch what who's the
king of the world Donald Trump most
googleable person in the world for four
years ran was the most powerful man in
history if you run the US military
nobody I mean you can bring down hell on
Earth on the world where is he now 71
indictments multiple weird lawsuits like
yeah so do you want to be that guy that
he's not the president Trump was an
emperor that's even worse than a king
what happened to Napoleon bonapart the
greatest general of Mo probably
statistically of all time nobody's ever
had 60 major
battles Caesar had Alexander the Great
had
six Napoleon had 60 and he won like 52
of them okay but how do most people
remember Napoleon because he was an
emperor he made people call himself the
emperor had a little narcissism going
there he ends up dying on in Exile on an
island of Africa called you know St
Helena so the people are gunning for you
Andrew Tate Ben shapir you see all these
people that are Elon Musk X he was
loved before he was an emperor I
remember first seeing Elon I went to a
fireside chat in 2011 a friend's like do
you want to meet this guy Elon M I'm
like I don't know who that is he was
more of a San Francisco local celebrity
MH all of a sudden fast forward 2022 you
take over Twitter X 50% of the world
doesn't like him because they perceive
him as a right-wing guy that doesn't end
well Andrew Tate it's like 50% of people
M at that's a that's an emperor level
and so a lot of dudes out there gunning
to be Emperors and Kings like my mentor
Joel Salon said be careful what you wish
for because the worst thing is to grow
old and realize you got good at the
wrong thing some people out here trying
to become men trying to become Kings
Emperors money all this at the very top
and then when you get there you're like
Mark Zuckerberg public record is he
spent 32 million on personal security
last year what kind of Life are you that
means you have credible threats against
your kids kidnapping you're dropping two
and a half million on security you want
to be that guy you want to be the prince
the prince I I I live in Copenhagen
there's dudes there Scandinavia Sweden
they they make a million bucks a year
they own a couple clubs restaurants you
know little online businesses these guys
are living the life that if that Elon
Musk or who whoever you want to say if
they saw that guy's lifestyle they're
like I trade for that yeah a couple of
things from that that I want to dissect
first of all how do you have the
bandwidth to be able to pull quotes from
so many different people to be able to
remember things from books because I
mean I read right but I cannot quote
like you can quote I cannot dissect
books in the same way that you can
dissect them is it just like getting
your reps in doesn't your brain have a
capacity for these things maybe it's a
weird superpower it's like everything Dr
bus is always like almost everything
good almost everything you answer that
with a quote that's because I think you
should answer with quotes because when I
hear people talk and they only say their
own ideas first off there's nothing new
Under the Sun so it's actually not their
idea and they're not giving credit most
of when I listen to most of the internet
is dudes regurgitating other dudes ideas
but not giving them credit so for me I'm
like people give me a hard time I'm like
I'm going to give credit where credit's
due at best in your life you'll have
three creative new ideas to bring out on
Earth how about Albert Einstein we
remember equals MC squ you maybe the
smartest man ever Steven Hawkin people
don't even remember anything so I don't
think it's possible for me I don't I
don't have I'm not as high narcissist as
people think and one of the narcissistic
seven subsets of narcissism is
self-sufficiency so I don't see myself
as a self-sufficient smart guy I see
myself as a guy who maybe has a weird
superpower being able to remember a lot
of people's ideas and synthesize them
into new ideas that apply for 2023 okay
so you also mentioned during the what
you just explained like encountering
Elon Musk and also yesterday when you
were talking and I was listening you
brought up Elon Musk again how many
times have you like ran into El M I've
had so that fireside chat was not a real
oneon-one but the first time I kind of
really talked to him it started in 2014
he I think he had moved I don't remember
his story but he had moved or spending
more time in Hollywood he's a real
socialite dude you see that new book
came out Walter isacson it's the Elon uh
biography it just came out a week or two
ago he really likes the social status so
I when I started Rising I'd go to all
the king events like I'd get invited to
Academy Awards I get invited uh to Game
of Thrones Premiere with all the the
actors so you always see him there I
would see him there I went to me and
Dolph lungren I don't know if you know
who that is but Rocky four the famous
actor the Drago I went to um the Cohen
Brothers they're very famous directors
get invited to movies and I sit next to
Elon Musk oh yeah what would you talk to
him about so I I would not say I know
him at an incredibly high level but I've
had a 25 minute one-on-one conversation
with him just me and him I would say
he's like he appears he's very sharp
opinionated strong and look he reminds
me of all the billionaires I know have
one thing in common um I'm in business
with two guys on the Forbes list I've
done business with four I mean I know
four of them they're tough you know I
call them the
Warlords build the top of the forbs list
is a whole bunch of Warlords they're not
Saints they're Warlords and sometimes
they're creative Warlords and maybe
they're important for society but he
he's a powerful guy that has strong
opinions and like the longest
conversation he goes we had met a week
before and then I was at the Game of
Thrones on my Instagram I said
interesting little video one of them
ones with me and him and he said to me
he said do you think I should use
Snapchat to grow Tesla this is 2016 when
snap was kind of new and Tesla was on
the rise really On The Rise and I said
yeah and I gave like a 10-minute
explanation line at the end he just shot
me down he's like I think you're wrong
not in a mean way just like I think
you're wrong he's like good products
sell on their own they go viral through
word of mouth and know I used to tell
the story for years I was like I thought
I was smart and then Elon just shut me
down
but I think I was right if I might be so
bold because a couple years later he
bought Twitter X not
only did he see the value and only then
did he become the richest man in the
world the man the true Emperors are the
personal Brands and if you own the
bullhorn Twitter X you have the power to
become the first trillionaire which Elon
has the power now doesn't mean he
wouldn't have been super successful
without it but he he realized like you
need social look at his Twitter his
Twitter every time he posts I see two to
20 million views on one tweet yeah he
posts five times 10 times a day that's
200 million people that's a continent
you reach a day I've had conversations
with him he's sharp strong opinions and
if you read that new all Isaac sick book
but I do know one thing he and I love
books and um whenever I've gotten about
books I'm like I don't know why was at
the HBO this is the one on my Instagram
I was on the HBO Afterparty and I have a
friend I tell everybody if you're I'm
not as extroverted as people think I
have this guy James swanic is the best
network on Earth so we're at this HBO
thing and Elon is right across and I
said D James go intro us let's go intro
to Elon and he walks right up he's he's
Australian he's like James how you been
he always confuses people by call not
saying I'd like to meet you and then
elon's kind of like trying to figure out
do I already know this guy like James
good to meet you good to see you that's
what he says always tells you want a
network you go up say good to see you
don't say good to see you again because
that's a lie if you've never he never
made Elon before but it's good to see
you and then they're thrown off because
they're like maybe I saw this guy
yesterday but he said God we want to ask
you a question so I came over and I said
Elon what's your favorite book and he
was dating a girl I don't think it was
Amber herd I think it was he got back
maybe with his wife Tula or something
and wife pulls them away they were
leaving and he and he was talking about
I like books but he was thinking on it I
said what book do you like the most he
pulls
away he loved books so much I watched
him walk 20 feet pull apart from his
girl and come back to tell me the answer
he goes Lord of the Rings I said why he
said because it shows that you should do
something even if you might fail I
thought that was kind of a great answer
yeah that one's on my inst you had to
grow back up 2016 what's your favorite
book why you don't mind me asking the
something's important
enough so Elon has a he he has a streak
of profoundness to him coupled with
extreme high risk taker like you know
you find that among most billionaires
then right yes I always say there I
think there's five SC actual
scientifically
validated uh wealth traits personality
wise number one 7
5% plus of self-made billionaires were
born to wealthy parents but or well
above average but that does not mean
their parents gave them the money the
way I interpret that is genetics as
genetics people don't like to talk about
but you can inherit warlord genes Bill
Gates father was a like the most wealthy
lawyer I think in his State I think he
was born in Washington state so 75% of
people are of Warlords as I call them
the billionaires are born to Warlords
Warlords give birth to Warlords there's
a good book on this called the self-made
billionaire effect it's kind of a
scientifically validated book so you got
jeans you could say inherited money but
I think it's jeans number two extreme
levels of energy they call it hypomania
if you read the story of people who
succeed they don't get tired maybe I
mean they need to sleep eight hours but
when they wake up it's like I have
hypomania I'm not as successful zon mus
but my cousin when she read that
scientific report she's like oh you got
that hypomania so I tell people get your
energy up it's hard if your goal
is to be a warlord you better be a isn't
that just motivation like if you're
motivated you you find the energy I
found yes but I do think people
have I mean it's kind of like black guys
black guy 10% of black men
African-Americans specifically have
What's called the super Gene the super
Gene is ability to put on muscle without
fat only 1% of caucasians have it that's
why I always tell people if you want to
be a personal brand you better get with
it because the whole world is coming
300,000 new people approximately come
online for the first time per day a lot
of that's in Africa and if you're a
personal trainer in America these
personal trainer dudes are coming out of
Africa I train with one of these guys
they have these insane genetics I mean
they like so I think there so that's a
physical super Gene around putting on
muscle mass without fat yeah I think
they're people born with an energy level
but before we get into that here's a
little fun fact I'm sure you guys are
all very well aware of the advertisement
that goes a little something like here
in my garage well that was actually
filmed on an iPhone and it got millions
and millions and millions of views and
generated millions of dollars in Revenue
so it just goes to show you you don't
need the most expensive equipment to get
started and today's sponsor streamyard
is here to help streamyard is a live
streaming software that allows you to
create high quality content with the
click of a button all you need is a
camera and internet connection and from
there you can stream directly from your
browser and when we're talking about
streaming we don't mean just any
ordinary streaming oh no we mean a mega
stream what's called a multistream which
basically means you can stream on
multiple different platforms all at the
same time which means more viewers all
at the same time they also offer various
analytics tools so that you can see the
success of every single live stream that
you do and then optimize from there for
even more viewership streamyard is
really the best way that you could get
into content creation and the best part
about all of this is that they offer a
free package to try out so there's no
risk at all to get started guys we're
not just saying this cuz they're
sponsoring us but we've been using them
for years it's the best way to get
started once again free package with the
link Down Below in the description thank
you so much streamyard and back to the
episode how do you acquire hypomania or
is it mostly genetic I think most things
are science is going to end up it's like
70% 60 70% genetic but you can alter it
I mean people don't sleep in
America you got to sleep Einstein said
he needed 11 to 12 hours a day so I use
this Aura ring I built this system
called 50 body I first built it for
myself now I kind of share it with the
world but need to try to get 150 minutes
of deep sleep when you track I get
entrepreneurs to track their deep you
have R yeah dudes ain't get I I meet
people getting 40 minutes of deep sleep
it's almost impossible the mind resets
and rejuvenates during sleep so you need
REM but I find most people's Rems not as
up as their deep sleep people
live you got to make your room cold you
have to make your room dark you got to
put on Blue blockers and de I I call it
you know decompressed 2 hours before you
sleep I I put in wax these wax earplugs
so like when I'm in Vegas here I can
seal it like some dude could be partying
next door I hear nothing you know and I
go to my farm a lot it's less it's
better fway but Le also I think there's
something to Too Much Wi-Fi I live in
Manhattan in a big highrise in
billionaire row it's called didn't sleep
good once for a year you're in a
building like you turn on your Wi-Fi is
like 6 60 Wi-Fi in your room there's no
way in a 100 years that won't affect us
EMF stuff all that stuff but for
billionaire upbringings in terms of
genetics wouldn't it be instead of
genetics maybe upbringing like having
highly motivated parents watching that
feeling the need to live up to that high
standards uh maybe a better education
right so I feel like all of those would
play a bigger Factor than just genetics
that's what the world thinks now I think
our grandkids will think we were wrong
and the reason is they're doing a lot of
twin studies they've been doing them you
take identical twins essentially have
the same genes let's say in this
scenario born to Rich parents the kid
one kid's taken and raised in utter
poverty my dad was born in Spanish
Harlem it was very poor you take that
kid and then you take the Kid born to
the wealthy parents who's raised by his
billionaire dad these kids will have
very similar outcomes 100% similar
outcomes no but shockingly similar this
will be the kid that that rises out of
the ghetto and becomes a billionaire now
people are going to argue with me this
but you got to look at twin studies it's
tremendous they used to think it was
more like 40 to 50% genetic I was just
reading the newest textbook it's by the
guy who invented the hexico score um
I'll try to give it to you for the show
notes that I forget the name of the
textbooks like personality now that
there's more DNA type decoding the
genome already it's up to 65% they think
of your life outcomes genetic now there
are some things that are more genetic
than others IQ is extremely heritable
it's called heritability it's like 78
height is about the same but other
things like narcissism is almost the
same
heritability um anxiety quick to anger
determination persistence it's called
conscientiousness all these things are
is that genetic though because couldn't
you see parents acting in certain ways
let's say anger you see your parents
blown up over things over nothing and
then you learn and internalize that's
how should be expressing my anger or
frustration before we decoded The genome
and then you separate a kid who grows up
to angry parents they never see their
parents get angry they grow up in a
happy family and they're the always have
The Temper you see that in animals you
know I think what where we humans go
wrong is to be homo saien in the modern
world is inherently to be a narcissist
because we don't realize that we're 50%
of the same gen jeans as a banana 70% of
the same jeans as a house fly
98% same genetically as a chimpanzee we
ain't that different and so on my farm
if you read a textbook on like cattle
for example you can genetically breed
meaner cows or happier cows a rottweiler
pitbull pit bulls are the just genetic
breeding for a long time the Roman
Empire they'd raise dogs they'd look at
the litter of puppies the meanest one
they'd keep they'd kill all the rest
they did that hundreds and hundreds of
times the mom the dad D and I took the
mean Dad bred him over and over to 100
200 most border coli dogs which is the
highest IQ dog they're all related to
one dog from the 1800s his name is WN
Wiston cap every sing how do you
remember that I used to I used to raise
B Collies I live on a farm I used to
train him in his Z Wiston cat look it up
w s t o n cap he's from Wales every fale
every Pro dog trainer would bring their
fly their females to get to breed with
Wiston he's like 95% of border call and
what dog has the highest IQ Border
Collies it's goes Border Collies then
poodles yeah what's the dog responsible
for 95% of all bites has like two breeds
that's jeans man you could find a super
dumb border call you could find a super
nice rot water but the genetics are
spitting out one ancestor so then what
do you say to the people that have BS
and they say no this is friendly dog
would never hurt a soul there's truth to
that but still people lie but numbers
don't it's still 95% of dog bites or
like two
breeds and it's just jeans isn't it
pimples and Chihuahuas chihu but nobody
from a Chihuahua I know but I'm talking
about like dog attacks I feel like
Chihuahua do CH for sure Chihuahua
attacks all things it's like all thing
it's just their mouth's not big enough
to break the skin yeah I have the owners
that think they're cute he's like oh no
it's adorable he's nipping at your leg I
read somewhere some one of those dogs
was like the Emperors of China it wasn't
it wasn't it was a similar the breed
that the emperor used to tell if
somebody was coming in to kill them they
would put them on their bed to sleep and
anybody who came in a little yippy Yip
damn CH it wasn't a chah what was the
one it was the Chinese Empire but by the
way you know talking about dogs and
having people break into my house and
genetics when I first started having
problems even before that guy broke in
I'd have people at my door people get
arrested outside for not leaving trying
to break into my place and talk to me
Beverly Hill's police chief came and had
lunch with me he's like listen get a dog
he's like we found houses with a dog
barking they just it's half as likely to
get you know broken into so I'm like
okay he's like I say what kind of dog
he's like it doesn't matter just one
that barks cuz people can't see it right
so me trying to be all scientific I'm
like I'm want to get what's the best dog
I Google it's like German train German
Shepherds from Germany so I actually got
a German Shepherd from this dude it was
like the best jeans he gave me the pap
those are how much how much was that dog
like Grand expensive enough that I flew
them down on a private jet I took a jet
to go get them and came back down oh
they're expensive yeah it's like a 100
G's for $2 the problem was as the years
progressed these dogs started getting
out of control and and one finally took
out the FedEx man it was I didn't get
sued thank God the guy was nice so
basically you Pro that's the gate you
there was a gate you could Buzz yeah and
I always told my staff when they left
close that damn door cuz I got the dogs
and one of my new staff left and kind of
cracked it open so the FedEx guy came it
was a new FedEx guy he just opened it
walked in I mean I I would have liked to
see that dude's face these two German
Shepherds just barreled and took him
down bit him in the arms and then I I
got I sent him to my farm because I was
like jeez I thought you the UPS
guyed guy I said him to the no no he
didn't die but he was nice enough to not
Sue I was like ah maybe the laws if you
walk in without that maybe that's why he
didn't sue cuz he shouldn't have come in
we had a sign it says you would think
his employer would be covering any
workplace in it broke the skin it was
just more scared to he was down on
the ground luckily we we could see and
we ran out there right away yeah but see
those dogs are not trained to kill
they're they're trained to just subdue
the person until somebody AR they break
your arm they grab the arm and like yank
it around and they knew German so I had
you had to do is like all the German
attack and you know it's pretty o or
whatever you're supposed to say to these
Germans so then I sent on my farm but
they were also problematic on the farm
they started hunting the neighbor sheep
and cow with those dogs though I heard
you also have to train them every year
every other year for like a few weeks at
a time that's why I had that Navy SEAL
security guy that's how he kept from
being bored from 88 at night to 88: in
the morning he would walk my house till
people started coming and he would just
walk with the dogs and train them all
the time but that time was in the day
wasn't he wasn't there and they took
down the FedEx guy it was my farm
neighbors were like bro I'm going to
blast your dogs cuz I sent them to my
farm and they started hunting they're
just breed to hunt yeah bread to hunt so
just like dogs like we are also mammals
like dogs so going back to what it takes
to be successful at the upper echelon
the stats are there and we can argue
it's you know it's nature nurture
causation correlation but I think it's
going to be more genes than you think
let's talk more about jeans but I we
need to finish the the three through
five billionaire traits yeah so it's
jeans it's this high level of hypomania
energy the third thing is almost 75% of
self-made billionaires were in direct
sales early Mark Cuban told me he he was
selling garbage bags door too or
something like that um if you look at
Steve Jobs he was like as a teenager
almost going when he was starting Apple
him in wnc he was going to huet Packard
guy forget the guy knocking on his door
like will you help me grow my brand Elon
Musk in if you read one of the
autobiographies previous one or
biographies he's talking about every
night at 9 p.m. he would call all the
sales managers in the entire United
States and help him sell teach them how
to sell because he knew the importance
of Bill Gates at age 16 17 18 was on the
phone selling computer stuff he would
lower his voice so they couldn't realize
he was a like oh this is uh William
Gates and he was doing phone sales Jeff
Bezos before starting Amazon was working
as an investment banker investment
banker is a fancy word for a Wall Street
sales guy I work with investment bankers
the good ones are sales people that's
why some people I was one of the M big
network marketing guys came to my
seminar yesterday I've never done
network marketing I think I probably
should have but a lot of people say it's
scam I'm like I think it's good man you
you you got to pay $300 to be mil to
network marketing plans you're probably
not going to be a millionaire from it so
forget that but at worst you learn
direct sales you got to know how to sell
I call it the king of all skills the
king and queen is Sales Direct sales and
marketing these billionaire guys are
great negotiators they're tough
negotiators that's sales man they're
also getting along with people different
personality types and knowing which ones
to where to push where to pull push
where but but I was going to throw the
next one that Dr Bus St me is low
agreeableness all the Warlords
are it's weird but in general I'd say
they have very low agreeableness they're
hard to negotiate with my
millionaire friends you can be like you
know what let's do a deal that's fair
for both of us oh not a billionaire he's
going to extract
that last penny out of you there's a
story of joh JD Rockefeller the richest
man in modern history 600 billion net
worth he would be sitting there doing a
deal and he'd be like the last minute
he'd be like you know what I got a
better deal for you and he was so quick
with math in his head he changed the
terms amortization schedule changed the
interest rate make it seem like the
other guy was getting a better deal and
he was switching the deal to his
favorite make no mistake you one of my
friends are Five Guys built online porn
they started PornHub five Montreal
Quebec Canada guys and I know them
they're all from Lebanese and one of
them told me a long time ago we were
just talking about business he's like Ty
all Empires are built by Blood Sweat and
violence so most of the dudes on the
Forbes list there's a body buried
probably outside of a casino here
somewhere everybody's looking it's like
which is the most virtuous Forbes list
people I'm like this is Genghis Khan
work guys man this is a till of the Hun
so yes I agree with you that
billionaires know how to be chameleons
and change their persona but deep down
they're low agreeableness they will
you better read a contract sent
to you by a billionaire I'm going tell
you that right now you better not
celebrate because they shook hands with
you and said we're going to do the deal
that way they will change the deal 5
seconds before it's over I'm dealing
with one of that right now with a dude I
won't say which guy with Ben Shapiro you
told the audience that they should go to
Ty lopez.com
quiz yes and that all business partners
or even romantic relationships should
take the quiz and compare it yes Jack
and I took the quiz the first time ever
I should see it we want to show it to
you but we're not going to tell you
which one is ours we want to see if you
could guess oh I can
guess all right I'm gonna have both let
me preface it with this I have a hard
time answering questions about my
personality CU I feel like it's always
changing and how I feel about certain
things especially if it's just a or b
you know what I mean I I need them to be
like very specific rather than more
broad cuz these are very broad questions
it's hard was that hard for you Graham
there were some questions that I didn't
know how to answer because I felt
neither one was like that strong when it
was either or Carl Young would have
probably said you're more of a Jay and
you're more of a p Jay's he called
judgers so judging people need to have
they have a hard time working in
uncertainty so the fact you told me that
tells me a lot about your personality
right now not Jack G it away it's not
good this test was not the Myers breaks
Myers Briggs is less accurate 16
personalities that everybody's taking
it's not the best so how did you come up
with this so This I have multiple
quizzes on life Compass I got a new one
out called on 12 types.com but this one
is a compilation of the most
scientifically validated which is hexico
NPI Mach 4 kind of Blended it's better
than it's better than the Yi and 16
personalities mys Briggs it's better
than the big five so these are all my
Harvard guys so yeah so I don't know
which one Jack shows you first which one
of you loves money the most is that
going to give it away it's just a
question I I don't know you all well
enough should I answer it or no I I I
think we'll answer if you if you want us
to answer we answer can I see both then
I have the other one you just swipe I
think this one is you the second one I
think is you could be wrong I I which
one is me you guys actually scored
relatively similar first all neither one
of you are Psychopathic good
it was a close one it wasn't it I think
this one's you which one is that let me
see I know you all well enough but I
think this one's you yes am I right
you're correct yeah I I could I think
you have a little I think you like money
more than I think you're a little more
money motivated is that correct correct
yeah that's my read before seeing the
quiz sure what gave it away in that your
response to money you neither one of you
are ridiculously greedy but were you who
was bullied more I think you were
bullied more I was not really bullied
authoritative parents authoritarian no I
don't like Authority but I I've never
had an instance you don't like Authority
not really I'd say my only experience
with authority is is through school I
just hated being told what to do in
school yeah he he hates being told to do
very so when I say bullying so the
definition so when you get high Ma you
got relatively high macu volume that's
61 you have a slightly more cynical view
but you both are very you got a 57 61 so
you guys are a little bit cynical about
the world technically mellian the
beginning of clinical mental instability
is a 60 so you got 57 and you got
61 um so you both share a slightly
cynical view which by the way you're
kind of journalists you're a modern day
journalist pod so my new quiz 12
types.com is more hormonal based you're
both a little bit what I call threat
based so you both have a little bit of
high qu result you have much higher
anxiety you overthink things more than
you so you're more of what I call
Defender you have a Defender type
personality that's very accurate when
you place it like I was looking through
that not fully understanding what it
what it meant yes if I could be cocky
about one thing I think I'm the best
person in the world at reading people if
there was a damn Olympics that I could
bet a million bucks I would go and try
to take everybody in the world's money
how do you do that I've been trained for
a long time and I've purposely pay I
mean Dr bus is always like Ty you've
tested more people as an individual than
any any psychologist in history I've
tested like 800,000 people on life
compass that I built that I have the
data I don't look so much at individual
people as I look at like metadata I've
also been trained by Dr bus who has a
PHD in Psych psychometrics which is the
study of people and he's the preeminent
living evolutionary psychologist he
wrote all the textbooks for Harvard and
Yale I met him in 2014 and we've been
very close he's been an advisor close I
sometimes talk to him three four times a
week and I have a female Mentor named Dr
Helen fiser who I've known for probably
7even years she's a PhD and chief
scientist for Tinder she has the most
data on human relationships of anybody I
mean imagine controlling Tinder data I
think to be good at anything you
need 30,000 hours of it the old 10,000
hours kind of archaic most Chess Masters
are like 20 30,000 hours so I definitely
have 30,000 hours reading people you
usually you need a troubled childhood it
makes you read people I had a pretty
troubled childhood so I learned to read
people to defend myself against you know
wackiness craziness trauma abuse you
know and then I think probably I'm
naturally interested in it you know and
then you get the best mentors in the
world then you and then I've also done
the data myself so I can I actually when
I go on seminars now around the world
I'll cold read the room and there's a
Norwegian guy doing a documentary I'm
like I was in London last month I'm like
everyone's going to say planted the
crowd cuz I read people so close he was
like what the so it's all going to
come out in this little documentary but
you can learn to read people some people
are more intuitive so I'm curious how do
you guys will probably become good at
reading people how do you tell if
someone's full of because there are
some people out there that I've met that
I instantly I can't put a finger on it
and Jack and I have gone back and forth
I'm like this guy is full of I
don't believe anything he says it's not
true that's that I told you both
Defenders threat based yeah but Jack
will say why and and I have a let me let
me let's break let's break this down
okay because it's not so simple okay we
have BS detectors yes and I would say
they both fire at the same time however
I am more of like a I need actual
evidence rather than the intuition
although my intuition is yes right and
Graham's intuition yes it does tend to
be correct as does mine but I don't like
believing something until I have that
hard evidence so that's where it ends up
what are your parents like my parents
yeah how do you describe them my mom I
would say
strict uh more of a
disciplinarian uh a little bit more
anxious very she can read people
extremely she's a kindergarten teacher
so she and she's done that for like 25
years so she has every single year a new
cycle of 30 kids where you get to
analyze you know their personalities and
stuff like that and then all of a sudden
you see them when they're 25 and she's
had that for a very long time so I'd say
she's very good at reading people as
well your dad what's he do my dad is
extremely easygoing what's he do he's a
real estate appraiser my mom is a
kindergarten teacher yeah so my dad very
easy goinging your mom your dad a number
guy he appraises things mathematically
for sure and you structur num you like
to appraise things you need I would say
so it's in the jeans baby comes in the
jeans you're like it's like you go he
needs to appraise the situation with
data it's like what does your dad do he
uses data to appraise real estate it's
funny how it works out man and what does
your mom and dad do my mom's a therapist
my dad's an animator her mom have
anxiety I don't think so she's pretty
calm do she overthink though remember
calmness is often super correlated with
anxiety I don't think so give her my
quiz it's very rare that kids read their
parents correctly funny and your dad
does what animator but he seems pretty
calm too if he worries about that I
can't tell but I say your dad seems more
calm than your mom probably but I think
a lot of it for me came from the sales
experience of like being a real estate
agent believing everybody and then
getting so many just fake stories that
eventually there were maybe some traits
that I would pick up on uh where people
would divulge too much information too
soon like they're trying to impress you
yes I tell people here's the problem
with intuition women are naturally 30
out of 100 at reading people men are
naturally 10 I think the people that
consider themselves intuitive are n are
like 40s out of 100 so it's kind of like
this let's say you just picked up a
basketball on your own you kind of
bounced it you could get good enough to
probably become a junior high or High
School level basketball player but
you'll never be a pro to be a pro you
must be trained Michael Jordan didn't
win championships till Phil Jackson came
in and a great mentor coach comes and
molds your natural skills and so I think
most people that are intuitive maybe you
guys are naturally intuitive you should
be molded and you can go from a 40 to a
90 you know you can become extremely
good I can read much deeper in stuff
that's not just things that my intuition
that 10 years ago I was still intuitive
but now I can almost it's very very hard
for me to not I'll give you example some
of it's just science if you meet someone
with tremendous amount of T tattoos
almost always they have high anxiety
almost all I was with one of the girls
that's here you know I she I guessed her
this was a Tinder date I met her yeah
and she's like I've never met somebody
that told me more specific things in the
first 20 minutes like I knew I was like
ah you had depression not 14 15 you know
and so some of this seems very magical
but is not as doesn't take as much
intuition as you think body modification
there's a lot of science if you just
Google body modification and anxiety so
people who modify the body a lot whether
it be tattoos all over a lot of
piercings very high likelihood they have
tremendously high levels of anxiety why
is that sometimes it's hard to know it's
like why do people cut themselves that
have high anxiety there is a glitch in
The Matrix of our brain that we just do
when we have anxiety we manifest it
in weird ways I I haven't looked deep
into that science but it's a good one
for people to Google but I also knew she
had depression why because comorbid
almost always people who suffer anxiety
have depression they're very correlated
there's a few people who have high
anxiety and no depression and there's a
few people have depression and no
anxiety but in general if you have
anxiety you have depression so some of
the magic trick of reading people is
just understanding the science of flows
you meet a dude who acts tough usually
has high anxiety guys now if you've been
to prison like my dad had very low
anxiety was a very tough guy had no
tattoos but my dad would definitely kill
you my dad had a different diagnosis he
had he had NPD narcissistic personality
disorder if I know you have MPD I know
you almost always have low anxiety these
don't go together um if you're a woman
there are certain questions you'll know
that women have borderl and personality
disorder women have it about four times
more than you said something that
reminded me of borderline you said you
kind of have a hard time understanding
yourself classic be I don't think you
have BPD but women for example if I'm
talking with a
dude men are more likely to be
Psychopathic women are more likely to be
have BPD women men call women psychos
it's such a misnomer you'll almost never
meet a psycho woman the definition of
Psych a practical example of psychopathy
is the ability to kill a strange strer
women don't kill strangers if you people
have argued I said let's go to Wikipedia
together let's Wikipedia of serial
killers they have a list of like the
last 1,000 serial killers it was like
six women 994 men there's patterns we're
not and we're not special snowflakes
that flow fall down there's there's
types I think there's only four main
types of people I have the four
archetypes there's and they're all
hormonal based so for example you are
more cortisol based which I can call the
defender or the threat-based they become
very good investigative journalists by
the way you're in my 12 types I got this
new quiz by the time this comes out
it'll be public it'll tell you what
career archetype you should have I mean
it's the biggest oversight in the solar
system that people go to Junior High
High School University nobody ever tells
you your archetype you guys you I think
you're more successful now as a
podcaster journalist then realtor
because this is your destiny you are a
cortisol based and some of that's just
genetic then the second type is the
novelty based dopamine person that's
what I am people are like T I don't and
that's also why I read a lot of things
and bring them together that's a
dopamine State that's why I have five
homes you know people like where do you
live I'm like I don't really I get
anxious after 15 days somewhere I want
to move so I set up my life to be
dopamine novelty based a lot of VCS are
usually dopamine based they they fund
300 different companies that's a that's
the archetype for a I'll tell you this
in the end but the third one is and this
is probably more you you're a serotonin
based structure based planner serotonin
makes you like I need all the data I
need to kind of pull it together it's
kind of the engineer archetype architect
type personality so for you it's like
this quiz is too Loosey Goosey I need
the structure to answer and then the
fourth type is what I call the socialite
that's the
oxytocin uh empathetic person so that is
the person who connects well by the way
what I was going to tell you be careful
reading people there's a lot of science
you can just Google this phrase oxytocin
and
trustworthiness men who have low
oxytocin are perceived as more like fake
false and dishonest but they aren't
always they're just like aggressive
people but that can be good 80% of Navy
SEALs are are clinical Psychopaths but
they save the world majority of
firefighters how are high in psychopathy
but when you meet them you might
perceive them like something's off in
these people you got to train your
intuition because sometimes the people
you trust are just High oxytocin
socialized that are brain has evolved
because a classic simple of uh symptom
of high
oxytocin is I ask a question in one of
my quizzes and I'll ask you both let's
see what I answer a large sum of money
is deposited and you and a group of five
men's account let's say this is what
you're the money you're going to have
for the next 10 years do you have no
problem delegating to one dude assuming
has moderate skill you can handle the
money you make the money decisions or
you more like wait a sec I need to be
involved in that conversation I would
handle it you would want to handle it I
would handle it myself yeah how about
you it depends how much money it is say
it's 10 million bucks 10 million bucks
going be you five are going to basically
live build your businesses and off this
sum of money I would want an expert I
wouldn't settle for anybody that isn't
an expert I would either ask Graham or
I'd ask and I I would probably ask if
they do it but I would want oversight
like I wouldn't fully just trust them
yeah yeah but you're you are higher
oxytocin you're a little more social
than you you're a little more like tough
guy a little lower on oxytocin I think
you would score low on socialite you you
don't enjoy socializing as much for no
reason 100,000 am I did I read you both
correctly I I much prefer socializing to
GR yeah so you are a lower you're I'm
like you a little bit so in that
scenario you said something so then by
the way so you have the four archetypes
then on top of that to complicate it
this is how I came up with the 12 types
hold your hand on for a second it's
called digit index ratio can I see yours
yeah you both have high testosterone so
you both how could you tell based on
that so digit index ratio you can Google
it there's great science on this it's
not palm reading it's not astrology in
utero when you're in your mother's womb
a certain amount amount of testosterone
is released this is your testosterone
finger this is your estrogen do it on
your dominant hand I have a lot of test
in a little you guys have similar you
have pretty high test you have very high
testosterone people confuse testosterone
they think oh steroids bodybuilding
forget that we're talking about in utero
testosterone okay so this isn't getting
muscles in the
womb and it's not perfectly correlated
it's but it's pretty accurate and so
risk
taking
cooperation
aggression so that's why I asked you you
are more of a socialite with high
testosterone you're actually complicated
let me step back you're a little easier
you should be you're the Civil Rights
activist or the investigative journalist
that should be your thing it's
interesting you call Graham an
investigative journalist because I
1,000% agree a th% agree there are so
many times I come over to gr's house
we'll be talking be like hey man did you
see this and like what and he be like
man I've been going down this rabbit
hole and I found out this and I found
out this and you wouldn't believe and
then I went back to this video that was
posted six years ago about this person
and then they said this and then oh and
then it changed up right here I mean he
did that right before he came over but
wanted that is because I don't trust so
many
people yeah but I if I catch them in
something then I know okay definitive
proof they're lying about this one thing
what else is there and you could piece
little but what I'm saying to you is be
careful like Mark Twain said everyone's
like the moon we all have our dark side
as you go deep enough you will love
nobody you will love there will be
nobody left if you could be inside the
mind for one day of whoever you think no
this is a good person I've looked deeply
there's no inconsistencies I've gone
down the rabbit hole I Graham have done
and this is the guy or the gal you get
inside their mind for 30 minutes you
might be like this is the worst person
I've ever met they may be having the
thoughts of evil at a level that's
hitler-like so I just look at the world
very differently I I think of and not to
say my way is better than you but the
way I do it is go I like Abraham Lincoln
learn from everybody even if it's not
what to do so it's just to me it's it's
like when I see Donald Trump it's not so
much is this The Virtuous politician you
ain't going to find one you can go back
2,000 years and you're still struggling
it's like Julius Caesar was he good I
mean you can't find anybody so to me
it's like what does Trump should Trump
be
president well part of me says hell yeah
I want a warlord negotiating with Putin
Biden's not a warlord billionaires are
Warlords who do you want sitting across
a table from a you know the first
trillionaire in the last 20 years or the
trillionaire is Putin he control I just
I did chat gbt on that stage you were on
I said how much is Russia worth
Enterprise Value if it was a country 4
trillion was the estimate well he
certainly owns 25% uh he owns the
military and if you you die if you don't
give him what he wants
so warlord number one Putin I don't look
that I want a president without
skeletons in the closet because who is
the man or woman is it Abraham Lincoln
well he didn't give a about black
people till was convenient for his
political career is it George
Washington the saint of America well he
was the richest man in the world so he's
probably a warlord there's a great book
about when his Chef who was a slave on
his farm for 20 years finally escaped
wanted to go see get to the North served
George Washington loyally George
Washington sent mercenaries to
ruthlessly hunt him down just to bring
people back and say I'm the king so is
George Washington a saint who is the
saint JFK he had tunnels for women he
said he had to have sex with a new woman
or a woman every single day or he could
he got headaches so he just funneled
women in and I think his wife knew about
it Jacqueline it's like who is the guy
is it Reagan is it I mean is it bush is
it Clinton is it Obama so to me the
second you go too much down the rabbit
hole you become an nihilist there's
nothing good you might as well kill
yourself you just the world that's how
people become nihilistic and depressive
you're like well when I begin to look
into Christianity what religion you grew
up with it's all or when I
began to look in politicians all Bull
and you just become a
nihilist understand that we're just
animals and when I'm on my farm I don't
look at this bull and be like this
Bull's trying to all the females he
don't give a about the other bull
I'm like no he's a boss tourist that's
the species I don't that's what a boss
tourist does what do Homo sapiens do
they are a very clever combination of
exploitation with cooperation be careful
of judging like Jesus Christ said
because if somebody measured the
Judgment back on you you may not like
the investigative journalist that's
funny you know it's like there there is
truth in that so it's good to be
investigative journalist just you got
all things in moderation keep it in
check does that make sense that does you
know you always do that right the
investigating I do he did that with a
girl I was talking to oh but it tell Tai
about the story I was this was my
favorite or you want me to say did she
take my qu I'll say it no okay so I met
up with this girl on Tinder we went on
three dates in four days wow she lives
in a different country okay I should I
nervous Australia okay she's here in
Vegas okay we going three days
everything's great sure I we kiss it's
cool that's it and uh then I brought it
up to Graham Graham goes He investigates
our Instagram finds a photo with a guy
it was a hidden photo with a guy she go
find a hid photo you call Zuckerberg all
all of her photos of her and a bikini
every single one of them but she would
have my this my story Jack but she would
have somewhere it's like five photos and
I went through one and it was like the
third photo in was her like with a guy
yes and I click this guy's profile cuz
they were a little too close and it had
her name as his Instagram bio with a
heart and he was priv by the way so it
was a private account and then she's
dating she's a girlfriend well we didn't
know that yet I facetimed her and I was
like hey what's going on with this she's
like oh it's my ex we broke up he's
inactive on social media and I told him
that if you ask a cheater are you
cheating they're going to say no so it
was pointless to even ask here's my
answer to you if you want my weird
worldw get okay wants to okay hold on a
second I have to share this I have to sh
this okay okay so basically I want I
want to say it you say Graham DM's the
guy well it's my it was my idea Graham
DM's the guy okay he gets back to us we
call him and say hey just letting you
know I went on a date with this girl uh
what's the deal with you and her and
he's all that and he gets all Angry he's
all we've been dating for two years I
bought her a car I gave her thousands of
dollars we have been together in a
loving relationship check this out sends
me a photo of his wall just Polaroids of
them all on the wall and he said thank
you so much this restores my faith in
humanity I oh restores and both destroys
and restores at the same the fact that
someone go out of their way to give this
guy a heads up it's the bro code if
that's happening you got to let the
other guy know he said that we were
Guardian Angels but he was saying what
what tipped him off was that she was
posting these fun photos and he didn't
know who was taking the
photos cuz it looked like in every place
like she's having a great time like
you're not going to be on Hollywood
Boulevard alone yes that's why I have a
girl sent you like a third party nude
picture like who the taking this
picture like hey maybe I want to have
this video she said that she would just
find random strangers he couldn't pin
her on anything so he just chose to
believe her but he had suspicions so we
restored faith and he investigated
everything he got down to the
nitty-gritty I knew it but that was my
intuition journalist but here's the
thing okay I'm G to play Devil's
Advocate because I see both Sid and this
is why I was saying if it was me and I
was casually dating this woman I don't
want there's no broke Cod I'm like don't
tell me I'm already assuming if you swim
with the sharks don't be surprised if
you get bit if a dude's dating a girl in
her Instagram has a PayPal on it he
should have known he was getting bit I
knew of course the bro code wasn't
needed what the dude needed was eyeballs
and non he got the eyeballs through US
yeah but he should have been non
delusional that man is I'm not sure you
young he was he was a young guy I think
this was his first relationship he was
obsessed with her yes I think that's a
learning experience you got to go
through as a guy get your heartbroken
like that and you can move on yeah but
even better is learn to read people
because you got to be careful of getting
your heartbroken too many times because
sometimes it doesn't go back and you
stay in that permanent cynicism place I
I think here's the thing first off
humans pursue short-term mating
relationships lots of women and lots of
men do ethics is a complicated question
because in every scenario if you heard
her side sometimes there's another side
I'll give you an example I knew a very
similar situation wasn't to me but
happened to my friend
when the girl was confronted she said
I'm dating a man that told me he'll kill
me if I break up with her said I will
kill you he was a jealous Latin guy and
so she's like yes I'm cheating on him
because I need I don't love him I've
told him 20 times he won't let me break
up with him and I need to find another
man so I can move into another
relationship because hopefully that dude
might even protect me so there are other
sides that's why I say the investigative
journalist must to be the true ethical
one must interview the girl now if she's
a pure liar that's fine but you wouldn't
be surprised there's an old proverb
every man's story sounds good until you
let the other person speak and
cross-examine you never know I I I tried
to break up with a girl once would not
she's known if you Google T I won't say
which one if Ty Lopez girl couldn't
break up with her Ty lopez.com
I do not I do not have for every
hierarchy country here's the descendants
no but it just people put it up and like
I couldn't break up with her she would
come drive up and be at my house and be
like I don't want to break up it's like
and so finally I cut her off she ended
act going she had a nervous breakdown
ended up in a home for six months I felt
bad but there's a situation where she I
had told her we're not together and
she's like we are together I'm like I'm
going to date other girls and she was
like she would come a week later and be
like you're cheating on me I'm like I
told you you think we're together I
after finally blocked her from being
able to come to the house I told my
butler guy don't let her in cuz he would
let her in cuz she was always living
with me so many side human mating is the
ultimate complex conversation and so
first off there's something called
adverse selection Tinder is a SSG a
self- selected group of women who tend
to be more short-term in general
long-term mating women are taken for
long periods of time so when you meet a
girl you know so you got to ask the
right questions on that first date you
know you got I can find out I've luckily
never really I mean I could have been
cheated on it's is impossible but I
don't have many horror stories because I
learned to read people and it's like you
got especially as a man becomes a prince
you're on your prince King you better be
extra careful I got a question though
because obviously I read all the red
flags I was yes I I knew what was going
on I knew it was sketchy but a lot of
your F his jack's first words to me
she's like good girl like so honest
loyal she like because you asked her
conscious mind questions never ask a
woman or a man conscious let's let's get
on to conscious versus unconscious minds
but I want to know yeah because
obviously hindsight 2020 but I
definitely remember thinking that it was
very sketchy and I was talking to my
friends about it and I was hiding all
the red flags from from some other
people Etc why do people know what's
best for them but they don't end up
doing that I knew it was probably not
good to continue talking to her yeah but
your unconscious what's good good for
example was she beautiful yeah Strong
Jeans your primitive mind The Whispers
of 10,000 Generations are telling you in
The Whispers of 10,000 Generations
people didn't live that long they're
saying mate with her have a kid she's
beautiful that means low mutation load
low parasite load high IQ probably in
her family IQ and beauty is also
correlated so your genes are speaking
it's not even the wrong voice speaking
you have a combination of the modern
world hominids are like let's say one .2
million years old precursors to Homo
sapiens Homo sapiens they guess is maybe
300,000 years old from 300,000 BC
approximately to 25,000 is BC we were
hunter gatherers and tribes relative
promiscuity or or I should say serial
monogamy um one man often had a couple
wives women did sleep around had
multiple lovers they've studied this Dr
bus lived with the asay tribe in Brazil
they're still pre-vis rainforest people
hodas all these then the 15 to 25,000
years became Farmers the rise of real
classic monogamy real classic wealth
disparities you still have like all
three of those brains genes don't change
that you have the homed brain that's why
men will ruin their life have built
their whole life career wealth family
they're driving a dude Cuts them off
they sometimes get out of the car and
murder that guy the guy didn't even see
you through the wind the Primitive 1.2
million year old homed brain you get out
and kill why' that guy do that cuz he
just he was in the 1.2 million then we
have this hunter gatherer
mind that's why we don't like the 9 to-5
job hunter gatherers even now the the
day they work about four hours a day and
they rest a lot and they joke a lot and
that's why the modern school system
doesn't work in the the vast majority of
homo sapian time you learn from mentors
you want to learn to hunt in the jungle
the old grandpa or the dad would be like
today we're going hunting follow me
young son you're 11 it's time you learn
and you weren't lectured in a classroom
Hall so sometimes you were with this
girl using that you know Hunter gather
mind sometimes we do use this mind which
is like that woman's my property that's
what happened with the rise of farming
so it's like she should only sleep with
me d d and then you fast forward and
we're in 2023 2024 and it doesn't make
sense our Behavior but it does to a
scientist it does and so if your goal is
to have a modern perception then you
have to override your primitive which is
hard and nothing more dangerous to a man
than a pretty face let's talk about
conscious versus unconscious minds
because you said this at the dinner yeah
that you should be judging someone's
character or just judging someone in
general by their unconscious mind rather
than their conscious mind which was
interesting because I've never thought
about it in that way I've always thought
that you you determine who somebody is
by their act thoughts the ones that
they're like forcibly putting ons like
they know their unconscious mind is
always ticking at the back of their
brain but they have the thinking brain
or the the conscious mind that is able
to then conquer that and I feel like the
thing that can then conquer should be
the thing that's judged upon yeah we
want to think but do we conquer the I
mean think about us if you make more and
for more forer ground a year you are in
the top one% of America which is like
the on Tenth 100th of 1% of the world in
wealth yeah we still want to make a
little more money it's not that logical
I know Amish guys like why you want to
make more money why don't you focus on
having more kids so we're still
primitive that's our primitive will
Durant calls that the equiv inquisitive
mind we grew up in famines in this one
million years ago so we learn to hoard
when things are going well you want to
make more money why does Steve wi try to
make more money and more Encore it is
bag you I like why so do I judge him by
sitting down with him and saying steveen
are you a good guy do you care about
others yes I care about what does that I
got no information from that
conversation the unconscious mind is
what Freud said you know man is like an
iceberg 90% of their thoughts are
underneath the water below your ability
to perceive it that's why when I read
people people often can't even read
themselves people don't know you know
investigative journalist that's
something that maybe you didn't know
maybe you figured it out now wouldn't
have been good to know that at yeah 12
it's hard to read yourself so how do you
cut yourself off um in terms of let's
say striving for more and more and more
like you gave the Steve win example how
do you know when to stop or maybe when
to focus on something else versus
pushing forward and saying I want more
and more and more well I think some
people are born to be Warlords I think I
mean genas Khan is the grandfather of
they say maybe 1% of the world so if you
kill gask
Khan like 7% of Asians disappear so I
don't think so much in right or wrong or
what you should do I would add to that
thinking tradeoffs so all I would add to
the conversation if somebody says Ty I
want to be on the Forbes list I did a
video Once on This and I said have you
counted the cost of entering the jungle
let me update you I didn't say you
shouldn't go in the jungle but I want
you let me tell you a story about snakes
leopards hippopotamus and quicksand
waiting to kill you maybe it's better to
just live on the periphery of the Jungle
you can step into it once in a while but
you could be in a nice quiet life so for
me it's not so much telling a Steve win
or a you or a myself stop is just going
have you counted the
cost because let me inform you about the
cost you want to be on the top of the
forp list you will There Will Be Blood
Sweat and violence to get there because
if you don't the other Warlords will
knock you off so do you really want to
be at the forb top of the Forbes list or
do you have other values I I think you
should remind people of other things I
have to remind myself like what do I
really care about I have a quiz called
Ty Lopez life compass.com 4M the four
unconscious motivators of man when I did
the quiz after I built it I took it
myself and I'm like yeah it's
counterintuitive my lowest Mo motivator
is material things lots of guys who try
to get rich or become rich they're not
Material motivated that's why I wear no
jewelry so many people meet me and
they're like Ty where's your jewelry and
I'm like well I never cared about it
what I am motivated by is movement
freedom and Mastery status to me is
better to be Leonardo
DiCaprio than it is to be Jeff Bezos I
think if Jeff Bezos spent one day in the
life of Leonardo Di Caprio he's like I
did the wrong thing yeah I made money so
women would love me and the world would
love me and then I didn't get it did you
see the picture when DiCaprio was there
with I just saw it again the
and she's looking at she's going to
leave the richest man in the world for a
guy who's probably worth 300 million but
has Mastery status has more movement
Freedom mating he's more attractive so I
I have a mentor in in dating love he's
this guy named mystery I don't know if
you ever most love mystery yes he's the
most famous pickup artist he hibernated
himself for a decade he was like the
most why it's a long I'll let you tell
it's a lot of personal stuff happening
to him but I was just with him in
Iceland and I like he does these boot
boot camps where he trains dudes I love
to go to him like I'm I'm not bad with
women already so it's not I'm not a
beginner but I like to just he's he's
kind of a savant and I was walking with
them once and he's not that Money
Motivated I said myy what's your take on
money he goes
well I get aist celebrity men I get
Sheiks from Dubai and Middle East coming
to me they have all the money in the
world and they're like teach me to be
better with women and mystery
says why' you want to make so much money
and the guy goes well I thought making
more money will get me more women but
then mystery said they got so good at
making money they forgot to get good at
women so the goal was mating and they
got goal hijacked and distracted by
money so mystery's like I don't ever
want to be that guy whatever you want to
be go straight to it so once you know
your four unconscious motivators let's
say it's mating then's better to be an
Amish guys motivated by mating big
families that money is a subset to get
that they don't care about Mastery and
Status being on the for plus they don't
care about traveling that much they want
this and they just go straight for it
and have great life they're the happiest
people statistically in America the man
who goes I'm going to make money
material so that all more men will
respect me I'll have more freedom to do
whatever I want and I'll get more women
is forgetting the first basic rule of
geometry what's the quickest way between
points is a direct line so if you want
Mastery don't try to make money to get
master don't you know who gets the most
women John Mayor this D would steal your
girl I mean just statist I always say
it's funny that now like I'm going on
fresh and fit next week and everybody
talks about body count and this and that
I think they're counting the wrong thing
I think it's love count I care less
about a woman's body count but how many
times she been in love you mean a woman
been in love five times deep Love by age
30 she may have burn out that love have
a hard time you might not be able to be
the sixth you know for men
you got to be careful how many times you
fall in love but John Mayor holds the
title I don't think he slept with most
women but he has the most aist beautiful
women that still can't get over him he's
the king and he's not that rich and he
doesn't have that much movement Freedom
he's not a tra but he has Mastery of the
guitar right he's a status so I always
tell man what do you really who are you
you're born that way but that Mastery
that Mastery I feel like way is social
status in terms of John Mayor is his
music impacts people on a very deep
emotional level versus being hey I'm a
master in Dungeons and Dragons like I'm
I'm the top you know whatever exactly so
be a master in the wrong thing if it's
if you know in terms of but if you like
Dungeons and Dragons I'll tell you a
woman will be more attracted to a master
of Dungeons and
Dragons than just a rich dude it's weird
yeah women are very I I would say you
know probably all human behavior is
mating driven but Mastery most of the
dudes who follow me and want to be rich
are actually Mastery driven men are very
status driven very very very status
driven so that's what I saying you may
be you remind me of somebody more
Mastery status driven I I'm not sure you
might be mating driven do you like the
thought of having a large family happy
family yeah I would say so yeah you
strike me as higher oxytocin you strike
me as a guy who's respected in his field
as one of the greats and not the whole
world respects you but you have the
respect of the people you respect right
that is important to you I think
Graham's a mix of Mastery and material
no I don't know well you I would agree
with that you also collect things Auto I
love collecting things yeah so you are
material Riven but I would say so it's
you're good at this but I I think you're
Mastery driven first and then maybe
material
if you had a choice I pick the Mastery
yeah if you had a choice you had to give
up all your collection and you you went
anywhere to any conference in your
industry in the world when you walked in
people wanted to talk to you the
interesting people the leaders would
want to talk to you and see you and take
dinner that's important to you I don't
think that's as important to you I don't
know if that's that important to Graham
he doesn't like going to events he
doesn't like socializing with people he
does like to have nice things and to
have status the respect of the people
you respect you don't respect the mass
okay that's what Charlie Monger said he
goes the earned respect of your peers is
the sweetest feeling on Earth it's not
the respect of the mass I get haters at
are masses I don't care you know you
care about the respect of the people you
respect right do you feel like there's
diminishing returns though in terms of
Mastery like let's say John John mayor
has kind of mastered his Mastery yes
does it Mak sense then to focus on
something else and master something else
or is there a diminishing return of like
doing too many things well I keep it
simple I just think there's health
wealth love and happiness that's the
biological imperative so no matter what
you think you are always have all four
of those as your main focus more
important than Mastery movement all
these health is the foundation wealth is
the fuel love is the purpose happiness
is the compass so what do I mean by that
Foundation if you don't feel
good you don't give a about
anything else there's dudes on their
deathbed or who are super sick and you
said you got to give me all your money
and I'll give you Health back they' be
giving all that money every bill I mean
you ever felt super sick I got coid and
I was super sick in London and I was
like I definitely start over with my
entire life if you would take this away
so health is the foundation of life mhm
wealth is the fuel
meaning just goes too slow if you
have no money yeah you can get what you
want but it's like everything's hard
when you got money you can save time so
that's the fuel love is the purpose of
life for sure I don't I'm not a
spiritual expert I don't know what
happens after I'm not a I don't know
that's not my expertise but on Earth ask
any scientist or any normal person and
it's like family family people we're
creative beings we evolve through sexual
reproduction we're not like ferns ferns
have asexual reproduction we're not like
earthworms you know they're
hermaphrodites they basically have you
know they don't have male female we are
male female sexual driven and the prime
driver of humans is to create a new life
we're creatives so love is the purpose
and then happiness is the compass often
times what we call depression is
accuracy we're giving people drugs to
overcome their accurate assessment of
their life so if you wake up in the
morning and you feel like sometimes
depression is fully biological but a lot
of it's situational and your compass is
just subconsciously telling you you
don't feel good because you
think you're going north but you're
actually going south you're going the
wrong direction ction so you got to pay
attention to your happiness Warren
Buffett for 50 years says I woken up
every day and I tap dance to the office
that's his brain saying you're good at
making money let's do more of this so
you can't ignore these four health
wealth love happiness the foundation the
fuel the purpose and the compass and
then so those are the things when you
are John Mayor and all of a sudden
you've mastered the guitar I would look
I'd be like how do you feel physically
are you eating good dude like if I do
private mentoring now to some of the
most powerful people in the world you
know I charge between $100,000 and $2
million to coach people that are but
these are people where that's nothing
right but I make people pay because they
pay attention I got some of my students
now are becoming almost billionaires
it's pretty cool I've been billionaires
oh yeah I got my first
student I've had many people like 5% of
the world's watched one of my videos
Google my Google reps are like it's a
lot have watched it either an ad or a
viral thing and I started a long time
ago more in a decade ago oh yeah so I
mean 80% of the big names that you see
making money these dudes all learn from
me where I have my courses in my
masterminds apply every almost every not
everybody Donald Trump wasn't but but
that and that's not cuz I'm so special I
just was everywhere for a long time it's
just the law of large numbers right but
what what I tell one of my guys yeah he
went 2017 when he started following me
he's making about 7,000 a month now he's
probably going to doing about 50 million
net with a business that he 100% of
that's probably Topline 1 to 300 million
it'll take one more year what's the
business could you tell us the industry
is in he's he's a big internet I'll put
it this way he's he has the mind of a
warlord what he now does is watches the
entire internet and scrape downs and
duplicates anything that's working he's
almost like an AI bot sure he's smart
he's would we know who he is no he's the
most secretive dude to he he he doesn't
like that he's a hyper secretive guy he
moved to Puerto Rico American citizen
but he's a sharp and but in
my coaching he never asked me about
money he's probably better at making
money than me you start netting 50
million that's a weird number there very
few people where your bank account's
going up 5 million a month and I got and
so but for him I'm like how's your
health bro and it was so to me it's
not like diversifying another business
it's diversifying to another pillar of
life he sucks with picking women he has
this problem you have where he's just
attracted cannot get over to whacka I
mean worse stories than you I won't say
it in case he's listening I want
accidentally but I mean just horrific
stories of women so he was with me in
Europe you know I have the sh he comes
Shadow me twice a year I'm just like
can't let that primitive mind there's
because he he's Rich enough to get the
pretty faces I mean the pretty one that
you know the the Willamina models the
Ford models and um but there're some
he's picking the psycho ones if you you
go straight to the top in Beauty you
better be a good Master of the mind
because you will get so I got a I
got a question right there because as
soon as you start increasing your status
increasing your Mastery Etc and you say
you have enough money to afford the
pretty faces what I always thought is
like the types of women that are
attracted to those qualities are not
necessarily women that I am attracted to
in general in the first place so like do
you think that the the qualitative like
internal character traits and
personalities usually go goes down or
the not the access to but like generally
speaking no like like the generally
speaking the dating pool that wealthy
people are interested in the internal
qualitative factors are worse like Jack
might do better being worth 2 million
than 100 million in terms of finding a
partner absolute that is all
billionaires suck with women I've never
met a billionaire that is good with
women all of them suck Google their
girlfriends or wi stories it's all
horrific stories right but that's
because they're so focused on making
money they don't understand like how
personal relationships work right I
think they got got gold hijacked and
they wanted like mystery said they
wanted the woman and they were the nerd
in school most most billionaires were
nerd bullied I mean just read the new
Elon Musk he was horribly bullied it's a
sad story but and so they want to make
money to get the status to get the women
and then they never got good with the
women and then they get the money and
like you said they move to Beverly Hills
you never date any girl from Beverly
Hills I live in Beverly Hills I never
you a girl is at of Beverly Hills that's
a disqualification to be at a Beverly
Hills Bar guys are like I'm rich now I'm
like bro you're getting the cream of the
gold diggers no you you have to change
you want if you are en counter you got
to change your geography you need a
second home oh wait Vegas Vegas is a
thin I have this I have this course
called 13 thesis that I built and most
common question that I've never answered
for 10 years was my opinion on dating
for an entrepreneur Guy high status guy
making money so I finally recorded all
the 13 my 13 hypothesis for sure my
simple answer is you got to change the
geography my friend Vegas you economists
speak of thick and thin markets here's a
simple example I have a private student
he's in Montreal he goes T I can't find
a girl I said let's start with the
physical and then we'll go on the
personality what kind of girl do you
like blondes well if you ever been
around French people there's no blondes
in France they're almost all brunettes
and Montreal's French I said this a thin
market so when you finally found find
the one blonde girl you like she's
probably so spoiled there cuz any dude
like blonde gives her tooo much I said
move to Sweden all girls are blonde it's
a thick Market of blonde women if you
like latinas do not move to Alaska they
moved to Brazil and all of a sudden the
problem is solved so I think PE men
don't understand economic terms like
thick thin markets and so they say well
I'm going to find the needle in the hay
stack in Vegas yeah I know most girls
move to Sin City because they like
sin but don't worry Tai I have it's
called the search problem that's the
mathematical word for it the search
problem we call it in modern colloquial
terms the needle in the Hast stack never
believe in your own abilities to find
the needle in the haast stack you won't
find it's called a needle and haast
stack because it's means you can't find
it so you should have two homes you got
to go where it's called SSG where's the
psycholog what kind of women do you like
blonde brunette don't care I would say
generally brunettes okay generally
brunettes I would say like the the
quality like I like intelligence but do
you like introvert or extroverts I never
ask men if they like intelligence it's
the science is in on what men like
almost all men almost all long-term
mating needs to be within one standard
deviation of your IQ that's like classic
evolutionary psychology so no man who's
a 135 IQ likes a long-term relationship
with a 100 IQ they just you naturally
it's called assortative or associative
matching we don't find two different
people so I I don't need I don't need I
know whatever your IQ is I know your you
know your 5 10 points around there so I
never asked that question start with a
conscious mind what kind of so you tend
to like brunettes tend to like brunettes
I tend to like like a little bit dark
eity ethnicity honestly anything I need
to ask you if you are answering what
kind of women does he like physically
let's start superficial physically I
would say somewhat athletic brunette
hair color doesn't matter that much I
would say for me it's more so like a
cute look like the girl girl next door
look I think who's uh has a very warm
heart I think socially intelligent
extroverted louder or quieter than him
uh probably slightly quieter okay I
don't think more extroverted I think
probably a little bit less but I think
age age probably 20 to 25 not older than
you I'm 24 so in your range okay yeah
tall or short short European or Latin I
don't know I've never been to Europe
aside from Croatia Europe is more white
uh I would say like a little bit darker
on the skin but like darker like Spain
Italy I don't know I I really don't know
here's the thing I I have this weird
thing southern Europe is my answer for
you you need you got the money to travel
once in a while right yeah Homo sapiens
were built we're not sedentary creatures
it's a total myth there's no science
behind it hunter gatherer you probably
should have two homes you got your Vegas
I would try Paris I'm afraid to send you
because there a lot of beautiful
brunettes but they just did a meta study
most mental illness in the western world
is France so be careful of Paris but try
southern Spain Spain's a great place so
okay the one thing I find very
interesting is uh that one thing I've
said
today don't worry I'm not easy offended
the thing that I really like is how
you're like you're breaking it down to a
science that I've never seen before sure
that is my priority and I've always
known that like having a family and
having a great wife and everything that
has has been a priority my Graham knows
this right my family knows this but I've
never thought to give it that level of
like maximum effort you know what I mean
yeah the the quickest way between two
points is a straight line don't go Zig
but here when I met Macy I was at a
point where I was so happy being single
and that was the moment and then shortly
after I in fact I made a video titled um
what the reason I'm single and then
shortly afterwards within like 2 months
of that video posting uh was in a
relationship like right after that but I
was at a point where I just like take it
or leave it whatever I was not looking
for anything you are very different you
are almost different species okay be
very cautious of extrapolating your mind
into the mind of others genes are smart
there's a it's called
f s d frequency uh sorry fds frequency
dependent selection nature very
specifically for the good of
mankind distributes different genes it
does distribute genes that two women
that are meant to be more short-term
promiscuous it's not the end of the
world it's supposed to be that way it
does distribute a very small percentage
of men to be extreme Psychopaths
approximately 1% so that you have Navy
SEAL Warriors so that when the enemy
comes to the gate you have somebody who
can kill with no remorse so yes that man
or woman must be ethical and legal but
let them be the Navy SEAL type you are
the family man and that is good and and
you are the Mastery person you got to
give both of yourself permission to let
the genes live out because I'll tell you
this you want to live a bad life you
know this saying don't fight the FED
yeah that's a classic stock market thing
the fed's changing in don't fight the
fed you will lose well let me tell you
something that makes the FED look like a
little piece of dander if you
flick off
jeans read the selfish Gene by Richard
Dawkins we are just we're like a blue
the jeans are the blueprint and they
build us and nothing I can do will make
me Shaquille O'Neal 7 foot2 dominant
basketball player so the second I start
going well I I I like that guy I'm going
to I'm going to really eat more give him
a little protein I really like Stephen
Hawking I like I really want to be the
physicist that unravels the world it
ain't my destiny don't fight the destiny
and the SC that's the spiritual way to
say it the science side of me says don't
fight your jeans you can't change him
why do you think that's such an
unpopular opinion it seems like these
days everybody wants narcissism's On The
Rise so you think it's a narcissistic
trait to want to think that you can
change your environment yes epigenetics
has some truth to it but it's been
latched on to by people as like well you
can change your jeans what the are
you talking about is a black man going
to turn white like what are I don't even
know people Michael Jackson has entered
the chat yeah but did it work didn't
work it probably contributed to all kind
he he couldn't he had the skin well he
had the skin condition no but I'm saying
do you look at a man who tries to alter
his jeans and see a lot of good track
record where you envy the outcome of
that human no you find the human look if
if you have kids my son my daughter your
son daughter whoever you have you got to
give him permission this his
civilization used to be I saw a video on
Instagram shocked me a kid born highly
autistic couldn't read Couldn't Write
nothing was put in the complete category
of not
intelligent 200 years ago civilization
want have given permission cuz we didn't
understand the genes I mean a thousand
years ago they would have said he's
demon-possessed
really 200 years ago those kind of
people were put in asylums if you don't
believe me Robert F Kennedy they took
their daughter and stuck her in a home I
mean they it was a horrible outcome now
modern we know more about jeans they
give this kid permission to grow up he
wrote he can can write an hour and 120
minute symphonies in his head you gave
him permission that's his
superpower so now you must give but
narcissistic times in the 1800s like
humans are meant to be this way you're
not that way you go in an asylum you're
a a pimple on society we don't need you
let people be now the question ethically
becomes what do you do with an adol
Hitler whose Destiny is to be a warlord
well sometimes you have to contain
things for the if you for the good of
mankind but in general you wanted to be
a family man or you wanted to achieve
Mastery there's no harm in it it's like
capitalism it's like invisible hat I
just read the the book you know the the
the it says let everyone pursue their
own selfish interest and all
Humanity prospers so let you pursue that
and if I narcissistically go well Tai's
not motivated like him so you know
there's no genes you should just change
yourself and you should become like me
it's like why do we really need more
people we want everybody to be a warlord
trying to become a billionaire you want
some people though sometimes warlord
billionaires like Elon Musk figure out
what NASA
couldn't so you need a man who's driven
by greed all billionaires are driven by
greed and by the way well you want I'll
tell you how to intuitively read
somebody do not ever think somebody
who's wealthy doesn't love money if they
tell you oh I'm doing it for freedom and
Legacy they are full of horeshit they're
not so give them permission you have
permission Elon mus to be selfishly try
to become the richest man in the world
and in so doing save the world maybe
that's okay you have permission to go
and just change your life and focus find
the woman find a woman it's fine be
happier man how long do you spend
learning versus doing what do you think
is the right ratio between the two I
think they're always in parallel from
day one till day 1 million the Western
World made a a big
mistake it was we have the classroom and
from 18 to 22 you achieve secondary
education University and then now the
modern stats is the average person
graduates from college in America
University doesn't read one book on
their own non-fiction for the next five
years I'd rather have like Bruce Lee
said I don't fear the Manning practice
is a thousand kicks in one day it was
the man who practices one kick a day for
a thousand straight days Mohamad
Gandhi's probably sta ically the most
influential person of our last cent last
100 years people think it's Einstein
it's he changed India and what's the
most populous country in the world that
surpassed China this year India yeah so
the most people in the world have been
affected by mamag and he wrote
autobiography before he died and there's
a chapter I was just reading it when I
was in Sweden he goes I believe in the
power of the guru he didn't say the
teacher teacher is a way to that
is a modern teaching is
you know what my teachers
taught me in school well Ty did you know
there's three types of learning there's
audio Learners about 10% of the
population there's you know visual
Learners about 20% of the population and
the other 70% are kinesthetic Learners
I'm like is my teacher using audio
that only appeals to 10% of the
people to tell me that you only learn by
kinesthetic doing and who do you do with
the mentor is the guide I do Brazilian
jiu-jitsu imagine meeting a
jiu-jitsu guy who told you he learned
jiujitsu on YouTube you would
laugh this guy out of the planet he's
like who's your now you call it your
Sensei and martial arts or your master
or your Guru so you want to get good in
this new business it's not about there's
no period of teaching it's when the
student's ready the guru will appear
find the guru and step into the field I
asked this to Kobe Bryant before he died
I said Kobe it's on my Instagram I got
to sit next to him there's these cool
seat at the Laker game if you sit next
to him looks like you're on the bench
you essentially sit on the bench with
with the Lakers and I sat next to Kobe
for two out of his three games and I
said can I talk to you in the locker
room after and I post it on my Instagram
and it goes do you believe in the mentor
he's like Ty yes he's like I learned
basketball from Michael Jordan they had
almost identical game he goes I learned
business from Bob Iger the CEO he's like
I learned to be a celebrity for Michael
Jackson these are my three mentors well
when Kobe Bryant had a $400 million
debt worth Bob Iger probably helped him
he had like four rings I think that's
kind of like Michael Jordan he was a
celebrity even Beyond his death kind of
like Michael Jackson yeah the power of
the guru the teacher is the scam when
people call me the you you know why the
teacher is the scam because the teacher
doesn't is teach regurgitating but not
to your personal situation how are you
going to have a classroom with 50 kids
in a university or 20 kids 20 how that's
not the the guru has is Jesus Christ was
a guru he has the 12 disciples Muhammad
was a guru I forget how many people he
had his right-hand generals we learn not
in the modern mind the conscious mind
learning that's why nobody knows
anything because you're appealing to the
conscious mind for 300,000 years of homo
sapiens most of the time we learn what
the guru the man learned to hunt by the
grandpa or the dad or the uncle saying
we go to the Jungle together they no
classroom now you do use audio
occasionally when they came back from
honey they'd sit around the fireplace
you know the fire and the the braz the
African you know Savannah and the the
guru Uncle dad would say now we were out
there hunting we you almost got killed
by the leopard make sure you point the
spear up into the neck don't try to come
on the top and he picks up a spear and
he's like try it let me watch you and
it's like
shadowing so you want to be a badass
well we'll take your business to the
next level is to to go from just the
Western mind into the Eastern mind and
the Eastern mind Buddha was the master
the guru you must become a disciple and
in the west you know how we get away
from that we call it a cult I'm like
America's already 80% of
Americans believe in angels and demons
I'm like don't be talking about cults
here Americans believe America is the
the greatest thing on earth maybe it is
I mean what's the greatest
but forget it it's okay to be called a
cult leader I people are like you quote
David bus too much I'm like bro I know
I've learned aund I've learned in 10
years what you'll never learn in all the
generations of your kids and grandkids I
believe in the power of the guru the one
difference I have and I would agree with
is don't have one Guru because then you
become a cult follower there is no man
or woman who has all the answers so in
the four pillars I have a health Guru
and I always like to have a male and a
female I find that nature distributes
babies and sexes in 50% ratios there's
almost always one boy one girl ratio in
the world so I have a male and a female
Mentor with working out I train with you
know Ben Greenfield or Dorian Yates he
won M and I trained female Becca Swanson
she's in the gift book record strongest
person in the world I'm not strong but
she taught me I have a shoulder injury
how a bench you know I can rip like 315
when I'm bulked up but I couldn't do it
before she told me tuck the elbows you
know it's like I could have been
in the gym forever repping sets I needed
the guru she's like no no no she's like
Tai bench
601 she's strong she's like watch this
tuck the elbows in tight if you T A ter
torn laborum all of a sudden I can bench
an extra hundred pounds that's the power
of the guru there wealth I have M my 67
steps is the five mentors that I had
Joel salad you know all the way and now
I have Tilman verti as a guy I look up
to he's on the Forbes list owns the
Houston Rockets I try to go once a year
is all the time you7 billion he gives me
good advice you know I've paid paid the
guru I paid Steve Balmer $250,000 to his
charity to have dinner with me for two
or three hours he's the top 10 richest
person in the world that's the guru he
gave me good advice he told me by the
way how to juggle a big family when
you're the CEO of Microsoft and how how
do you do that his advice was
Excel which he invented I thought that
was cool he's like I had a spreadsheet
to make sure I always spent time he's
like I was the CEO of Microsoft I'm not
GNA be able to go to Every football game
of my son but I just had I used Excel
which he invented with Bill Gates and he
just made sure he went to like I need to
go to like 15% of my son's games no
son's going to look back and our dad was
worth a 100 Bill and be like Oh my dad
didn't come to every game like I
would have liked to have a dad that has
100 bill but I wouldn't want him to come
to no games so he just used ratios and
balance and math so I learned that from
that guy when you can't figure out your
life use math math is the language of
the Gods man math is one of the
languages of Gods love you need a mentor
I have Dr bus and Helen fiser they
taught me a lot about the psychology of
mating and then happiness I have the
Amish I live with Amish for two and a
half years they are Jared Diamond who
has a pullitzer prize winning book The
researcher from UCLA when he found out I
live with the Amish he's like I studied
the Amish they have 500% or the modern
world has 500% more depression he's like
oh you that's I want to meet the Amish
they're happy so after this Vegas I'm
swinging through fresh and fit in Miami
I'm going right to the Amish farm that I
have
it's in the middle of Amish community
now why not get married have kids
because a lot of people say that is the
way to be fulfilled and be happy kids I
never talk about kids so people always
say why don't you have kids how can you
I'm like how do you know I don't have
kids some things should be done in not
on social media for safety H don't put
if you're well known don't put your kids
on social media what are you doing
that's my opinion like what are you
doing opening up for weird
on social media to look at
your kids but I'm not a marriage type
yeah I guess two questions um Love Yes
marriage is man-made invention if you do
have kids yeah how would you think that
would change your perspective on life no
because I I have that experience and I
has I mean I think kids always change
you but for me it's it's just driven
home don't forget all four pillars of
Life have kids if you want to make money
every dude who made money had kids
before 30 people have this B I mean
people don't know math I meet guys like
all I get these students I'm not going
to have kids to because I need to make
money I'm like where where do you get
these facts what facts are you
looking at I'm like you know the Forbes
is better than horard NBA Forbes list
forbes.com realtime list let's go
through number
one Elon Musk has 11 kids he had like
five of them before age 32 okay he
seemed to do well with money okay next
Jeff be
lot of kids before age 30 as I go down
the I'm like wait a sec I
inverted my thinking to get rich you
have kids before but it seems as though
the quality of life of some of those
maybe isn't as high like maybe Elon Musk
is not as present of a father as someone
else who's not on the list but that is
at any age he's just not that kind of
guy Jeff Bezos is his kid I just saw his
New Year's picture he's partying with
his kid I think he grew up with his kids
Steve Balmer is like I was with my kids
all the time every day if anything
Warren bu it had kids young and didn't I
don't I I don't think there's much
science I think this science causation
correlation whatever you want to slice
and dice the data my answer is a man
should have kids the second he finds a
woman who meets all five archetypes of
long-term mating the second so if you
find one now you should you need I once
asked Dr Buzz what's the minimum time
you need to know a girl before you would
have a kid with her and he said probably
a year but it doesn't need to be 10
years to to me it's seems as though from
my perspective 33 no kids yes want kids
one day yeah I recognize that I'm not in
a head space to sacrifice my free time
enjoyment stressfree life for a child at
this point but that's the conscious mind
I feel like it's the unconscious mind
too no the if it was the unconscious
mind you wouldn't be able to say it it's
hard to say the unconscious mind no I
think it's I think it's a lot of
introspection of why would not want a
child right now but at 30
eight I think that would be is she your
is your girlfriend the same age roughly
she 25 it's crazy a woman has like 4% of
her viable eggs that she had in her
lifetime left at age 30 women got to
look at data men it's not as scary that
doesn't mean women can't have kids into
30s 40s my mom had my last but the age
at which you have your first kid makes
it much easier so my mom had me at 24 25
makes it easier to get pregnant later
now we have all kind of I F stuff so
women will get mad and say but ideally
you're having kids without too much
chemicals if you can't have kids you
know if you're 40 as a woman you don't
need to have a heart attack but woe to
the person that thinks biology goes on
their man-made timeline biology is a
ruthless don't give a
doesn't give a that there's
differencing men and women it's like
this is how it is and that's the mind of
God so I'm not necessarily saying God
like a religious God but it don't fight
God I don't know I you may become yeah
you may get everything you want if you
had a kid this year faster than you
thought you would I don't know about
that like for instance travel is
something for me that I would like to do
more of and I think traveling with an
infant I couldn't do that I couldn't be
present in a new space and fully
experience it in the back of my mind no
other a kid at home for about a year you
don't travel as much and then the kid
becomes smarter as you take them with
him so it's the ultimate win-win kids
but
uh you know I I like doing my you know
what I would say to you think like a
Quantum physicist don't have certainty
you by the way on that quiz you have S
High superiority narcissism who thinks
they're right a lot mom or dad uh I
would say neither neither if if I had to
pick don't have strong convictions if I
had to pick I would say my mom she's a
therapist so she comes at everything
from this is what I've seen from my
clients and based on this this is what I
believe with his mom yeah a couple of
times do you think she has strong
convictions I would say much more so
than his dad my dad's very easygoing
he's very much go with the flow let me
see that he got I'll show you something
interesting on here so there's seven
subsets of narcissism this is a very
tricky one that you should know about
yourself so you have this is on there's
seven subfacets maybe I don't know if I
can hold we'll put a screenshot on so
Authority
narcissism you get
out of a 100 you get an 87 so you're
almost 100% Authority narcissism and
what does that mean you think you're
right can we just one moment right there
to appreciate that because that is
100,000% but a lot of character I am
right yes but so let here's my advice to
you on this you've been given a gift and
a curse what God giveth she taketh away
or he taketh
away
The Authority narcissist must make
sure that they have credentials on the
things they speak on what I'm telling
you you should get more credentials on
the question of what happens to a man
when he has kids where you get in
trouble with authority narcissism is
speaking on too many subjects you also
have superiority relatively high so in
general you will take the vantage point
that your ideas are superior to others
does that seem accurate I would say so
okay the good news you don't have
exhibitionism narcissism you do not try
to show off your body sexually to other
people there's no thong or thong I would
agree with that okay entitlement you're
not bad you're below 50 so you don't see
yourself that the world must give you
things you're willing to work for them
that's good exploitative you're not
tremendously exploitative you do not
ruthlessly utilize your skills to make
others lose so you can win no no Tesla
insurance by the way you're that was a
joke you're also not super low yeah some
people like the Amish score zero on
exploitative but you're not tremendously
exploit no he's not I was making a joke
vanity believe it or not you do look in
the mirror more often than of than
people may think you you you look at
that thumbnail and like do I look good
in this picture more maybe it's not and
then you have self efficiency narcissism
here's these two are relatively
innocuous yet dangerous self-sufficiency
is like I will figure it out yes the
truth is not within my friend if you
want to learn Chinese you got to go to
China and the man who sits and goes I
will meditate through iosa absorb China
I will download Chinese through the you
don't speak well so your main but it's a
superpower yet it's like being seven my
stepdad's 6'7 it's a superpower yet he
knocks himself out sometimes
I've seen him almost kill himself
running down the stairs at a log house
in Virginia and he hit his head on a
concrete thing I was like he's dead so
you're going to have to be careful you
have a superior you have a strong mind
yet that mind if it's not held in check
you may find yourself B on the floor and
you hit your head hard enough you might
not wake up so you must surround
yourself with true experts you need
gurus in all areas don't work out on
your own I'll give you the phone number
of Dorian Yates pay him 300 bucks work
he'll work out sure one workout with Mr
five or six times Mr Olympia will be
better than all the self- learning but
so yeah what would you optimize if you
were me right now in my life what would
you change and what would you improve
just based on how well you know me our
conversations what I should tell you or
what you'll listen to both what I should
tell you is you should have kids
relatively soon sub 18 months throw all
that garbage out the door there's no
data and it won't be true and you'll
thank me later you have the money and is
your woman psychologically stable she
nice yeah low exploitation have her take
the quiz before I tell you to have kids
with her let me see but assuming you
know what I could call her and ask her I
I don't she'd appreciate that though but
to take the quiz yeah no like right now
well it's a long quiz but I will talk no
it took me it took me 10 minutes I could
do it on you mean do it live we can do
no no no she just do it call her have
her don't say you're talking to Ty Lopez
no well you can't she she's never in a
podcast yeah do you think the results of
our tests would determine that we are
good to be business partners or bad to
be business partners or what um I think
Myers Briggs is better for that a lot of
scientists don't like 16 personalities
Myers Briggs I find it's good for like
business
partners it probably I mean use the
Peter Ducker feedback methodology how
long ago did you meet gr and I four and
a half years ago give or take so Peter
Jer wrote this I put it at on ty.com
books I list out the best books I've
said I've had it for 10 years the top
100 books you should read in order just
read those 100 books a lot first one I
put is Peter ducker's little pamphlet
called managing oneself he's cons my
mentors saw Peter Ducker as the best
business teacher of all time he's very
esteemed and he's dead now sadly I never
got to meet him but he
said most people think they know what
they're good at most people are wrong
more people than not think they know
what they're weak at even then more
people are wrong than right yet you can
only build off strength so what I was
telling you about you're only going to
be really good your thing is going to be
mating man your thing is going to be
Mastery it's the Flow State your flow
state is going to come from having a
cool family and all it doesn't mean you
won't make money it's going to all
emanate like a spoke in a hub situation
you know for you is like your love will
emanate out of Mastery you'll make your
kids Masters you'll make your you'll
probably give birth to more people that
are family oriented so going back to
this conversation about are you two good
business partners we use PE he also says
in that book so how do you know what
you're strong at he says use feedback
analysis write down what you first
thought so if I could had a time machine
I go back to when you met four years ago
and decided to be business partners what
do you think the outcome will be I'm
assuming you would have written I think
this will be a good partnership we'll
make more money together than we would
have it would have been successful he
said then wait a couple years look back
and and was it true do you think you
guys have done better together than you
would have done along do you relatively
get along without crazy mhm yeah you're
probably a you're a
strength where people go wrong is what
you did what do I want out of life I
want a girl that I can trust I have a
long-term relationship and then you
wrote it down and you start going on
dates with her and then all the red
flags started going and you're so it's
like I think by going out with her I'll
get my goal then you
ignored the red flags so you're ignoring
feedback analysis the analysis was nope
it ain't going to work out she probably
has another boyfriend she probably high
on promiscuity or there's a thing called
the sexy s which is like all your
sexuality goes on this sexual seven
she's probably like higher on
promiscuity some people genetically are
very monogamous you know men think all
women cheat it's just not true there's
like it's very genetic I I tried to go
on long-term partnership I've been with
women that you just these are not women
who cheat it would take an incredible
that maybe if they crash landed on a
desert island and were with another dude
it would still take a solid year before
they'd sleep with them even though they
knew they never get back you know or
there's some women men went to World War
II and they were missing an action and
never came back and that woman took 10
years to get remarried monogamy is a
gene so you were ignoring a woman who
has a propensity probably genetically to
be short-term
juggling they found that in the
rainforests there's a famous book Helen
Fischer has it in her book called why we
love she talks about her experience with
hunter gatherer tribes she said there
was a woman in a hunter gatherer tribe
before Instagram before Tik Tok before
only fans before porn I'm talking pre-
civilization and this woman had 18
Partners she had
had it's just a genetic thing so this
woman is probably her genan her
bloodline comes out of that promiscuous
thing and you need to go I'm writing
down what I want I'm assuming you don't
want a woman who cheats on you mhm you
don't want a Harum I'm assuming it's not
super important to you so like I want
one woman that I can really focus on
find beautiful could see myself maybe I
won't marry her instantly but there's
potential and then you go out with a
chick lots of bikini pictures
lots of bikini pictures Ain't That Girl
In fairness I didn't get burned in it
because I I did have the walls up
because I'm like okay like obviously
this is not like checking all the boxes
but I was
I was more so intrigued because it's
extremely rare I ever go on a date with
a girl and I want to go on another
pretty but this was an exception so I
was like I was like wondering why 1 to
10 what was her your sexual
attractiveness to her eight compared to
all the women you've been on a date with
not compared to the world
eight8 n eight and a half what was the
thing that was what did I like about her
um I would honestly say it was her
personality I think she she had a lot of
the strengths where I find weaknesses in
myself and I found that attractive um
she doesn't care at all like about being
kind of like a public nuisance and a
little crazy and a little this and that
and more orderly I would say so I found
that attractive so you're doing the the
young Carl Yung thing like we we marry
people to offset our weaknesses the
introvert marries the extrovert so you
have extroverted more extroverted but
realistically a better lifelong partner
would be someone who shares my so I
would say In fairness she said she did
this with her F not with her family but
like she know kind of speak with her
family so it wasn't uh she's very
similar to you very Comm we often Shadow
date meaning we date our Shadow super
common sometimes people people always
say I'm attracted my opposite I'm like
are you sure you're not Shadow dating so
very similar um likes money success
important to her am I right no I I don't
sure I think so are you a successful man
I am when a woman dates a successful man
she often cares about it I meet Rich
guys are like bro I'm like did you meet
her before or after you were making but
to me she's the most frugal person but
that that doesn't that's actually mean
she loves money often times frugal
people love money your biggest obstacle
with each other she she seems you know
she has high vanity like you high
Authority very similar traits and high
self-sufficiency is you're you're kind
of dating yourself very common my cousin
always dates
himself um and sometimes that can be
good the main issue she has and will
have independent of you or not is she
has 100 out of 100
anxiety so she's a classic
overthinker is that true yeah this is a
very tricky one and you have 78 out of
100 on anxiety now is this 100% true
it's not the exact number the point is
on a spectrum she is in the high range
of and when I say anxiety it's
not I'm worried every time yeah yeah but
it's a little more neurotic it's a
little more oh yeah it's a little more
it's a little more can't sleep because
can't turn off it's a little more hard
does she ever sweat the small stuff
sometimes yeah that's anxiety yeah all
people become anxious when their house
is on fire we don't call that anxious we
call anxiety that I'm also worried about
like just you know like am I out of
water like everything becomes a little
bit elevated is she a little bit that
way yes I will say a confident yes yeah
so it's fine I mean look women score one
thing big difference between the SE
Sexes see she stores zero on psychopathy
she's not a psychopath at all she would
not kill she if an intruder came in
don't give her the
gun don't get she might go well if I
shoot him he'll be hurt so I don't want
to shoot him and you're like that's the
point he's a Intruder hurt him
she's not out to hurt people she's a
little bit tricky though she got a
little tricky side to her she is a
little bit know how to say things to get
her way that's what I would say does she
know how to get her way sometimes yeah
what she look where she what's her
background in terms of culturally
culturally well same as Jack just from
she's white yeah not Asian okay no does
she know how to get her
way I mean yeah I would say so I know
you don't want to incriminate yourself
too much I should ask him I think he
doesn't want to incriminate himself
either well this is me saying it so I'm
incriminating but I mean this is this is
not a tremendous red flag she does care
about material things more than you
think I would say but she's I would not
put her in the Gold Digger category she
doesn't score full gold digger but she
also doesn't score Mother
Teresa monk who gave up her Ferrari sure
she's not the monk who will give up the
Ferrari she likes this house it's a good
house this is a hell of a lot better
more than most guys that show me their
girlfriend and it's not about perfection
there is no perfect score it's more
about tradeoffs meaning you are your you
you're not a I would say if this was my
best friend saying I'm going to marry
this girl I wouldn't have to have a
heart to heart with him which I
sometimes do I'm like listen my friend
this chick is death and just is the
green reaper so no I would say these are
these are fine just anxiety a lot of
women have anxiety is estrogen at work
man I read a book where a guy wanted to
understand his wife so he took all this
estrogen injections and um he said I was
walking down the hall and I saw out of
the corner of my eye some like puppy or
something on TV and he's like I started
crying and I didn't know why I was
crying and his wife turned to him and
said now you know what it's like to be a
woman and so women are built that way
and Society doesn't like to talk about
it but biology and Society
biology is God and Society is man-made
so you know so it's fine I I don't see
crazy red flags put that okay appr you
like money a little bit more you do like
this house a little bit more and you
know what yeah that's good because you
would not like a woman who doesn't
respect you at all for your ability to
make money so that's what I said
sometimes people go is this good or bad
I'm more like ah you seem very similar
interesting so all of the good things of
your long-term partnership will come out
of similarities and all the conflicts
will come out of your similarities and
nobody's perfect fa all is all going to
emanate you both will have a little bit
of anxiety and you will wig each other
out sometimes you will freak each other
out once and when you're not operating
in your best space when you haven't had
enough sleep you will freak each other
out a little bit thank you is ever
happened oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
definitely I told you I can read one
thing I'm cocky as about I'm like I
don't think any person on Earth can read
people better than me and if you can
Jordan Peterson oh I don't think so
I don't think so Jordan Peterson's a
disciple of Dr David bus my mentor but
I've wor now that sounds Cocky by the
way I listen to Jordan Peterson I don't
think there's an omnipotent person but
I'm cocky enough we put a million
dollars down I will read a cold room
versus anybody even my mentor Dr bus
sometimes the the student becomes
greater than the teacher in fact the
great teacher always makes the student
better or the guru so anybody I train I
want everybody that I teach that's I was
so excited about this one guy was within
Europe like bro you're making more money
than me the guru is working I have many
people I was just with a guy yesterday
last night that one dude I met him gave
him some advice in France and made he
flew here I don't know if you knew one
of the speakers but he SP right before
you at the dinner he was like Ty you
told me one thing in five minutes I made
an extra 400 Grand this month net not I
mean it's like I've I've helped a lot of
people make money the gur my point the
reason I say I'm the best is just
because I actually think I am because Dr
Peterson is slightly different than me I
don't know that he reads people as his
prime interest one-on-one he was an
actual clinical you know I think
psychologist I'm not a therap I'm not
good at fixing I'm not interested in
fixing people I haven't built the
credentials interest you know Dr bus
says Ty you're the best guy on Earth
that doesn't have a PhD Dr bu talking
about himself but I have a lot of data I
have a lot of social media followers and
I have an interest in a pinpoint thing I
couldn't Dr bus uh Jordan Peterson would
be much better at maybe trying to fix
you because I often tell people what
you're most sure of is always the thing
you're the most wrong about or as
Frederick n said convictions are greater
enemies of the truth than lies be
careful of what you're convicted on a
lot of people have convictions America
like I know you be president I'm like
bro you can't fit You're On Life's in
shambles you know should you know how
America should be run you know how to
run a 20 trillion GDP you got all the
answers I'm like bro your life's in
shambles where do you get this
confidence I'm like you need less
convictions convictions are greater
enemies of the truth in fact my first
YouTube video ever when I launched my
channel I think 2013 or 14 I was in
London and I was in the back of a taxi
and I said I'm not even going to use
words the root of all evil in history
is and not going h
so when someone challenges your
conviction and your first answer like
you're wrong that's the root of all that
evil people told Hitler nah don't do it
and he was
like you know
people what was it Dread Scott the
Supreme Court is like black people are
two-thirds of white people or whatever
it like a it was literally a gavel goes
sueme court it's like the root of all
evil is strong convictions by people who
don't know who don't have the expertise
and even then people with 30,000 hours
of expertise make mistakes so imagine
having one hour of expertise I tell
people stuff I'm like bro you have one
hour of expertise we all have the dude
who's out of shape who is on YouTube
videos criticizing oh you got to take
the steroids I'm like bro you
know nothing about Fitness you just got
to shut up on those subjects you know I
sometimes people say but Ty you have a
lot of conviction on a lot of stuff I
always steer the conversations into
things things that I have a lot of Guru
teachers or I try to if you ask me stuff
outside of my skill set I try to shut
the up I probably overstep
sometimes but it's a dangerous skill to
have why like people ask me who should
be president I'm like I it's not my
hurry of expertise man Biden seems to be
horrific Trump you know I'm not g i
don't have super strong conviction on
that it's not my thing I don't have a
guru who studied
presidential I've read a few but I don't
have enough political Savvy you know I'm
a health wealth love happiness guy I'm
just like put your head down focus on
your own thing I can give you a lot of
advice on your thing and reading per
people follow this thing on your destiny
and or strength that will change your
life forever it'll in fact be the
compass for your life now that you know
you're a Mastery guy and by the way the
reason you're not so interested in
mating is because much
lower in your unconscious mind the
danger though when I say mating is lower
for you it shouldn't be low it can't be
a one or you just disappear you know you
have good genes you have a mind you have
this this is important like Elon M said
is like underpopulation is the real
threat to humanity or what I I think
that's I don't know if I agree with that
I would say the enemy of
humanity is the wrong people having a
lot of kids you know Johan Sebastian
Bach the greatest musician of all time
had I think 20 children m that didn't
hurtt the world it's like six of them
became the greatest musicians alongside
their father I'm like every Yan saan
Bach should be having kids now you go I
grew up kind of in the ghetto Long Beach
Compton there's people in there it's
like both parents are alcoholics they're
have tremendous levels of
schizophrenia or psychopathy maybe they
should have one kid only you know but
I'm like now people don't like this
conversation cuz it sounds like Eugenics
yeah but I'm not talking about
sterilizing people I'm just talking
about common sense I'm like you might
not want to have 20 kids you're
come from seven generations of but I
didn't say they can't have kids my I'm
more about how come like I live in
Sweden it's like a very wonderful place
and and they have no kids it's like that
they're not even having you got to have
two kids to keep population maintained
and they're having like 1.8 and I'm
going you guys got resources it's
relatively functional Society you guys
should be having four kids and then
there's places in the world they can't
even feed the second kid they have they
need to slow down and do what you're
saying build themselves I think
sometimes you just get fulfilled through
other means besides raising a family and
it for for some of these people having
1.8 it could be well I have a great
career I have a great friend group we
don't need to have more kids you know
one is fine none is fine Joel Salon said
nature laughs last Nature's already
laughing at Sweden I love Sweden I love
Denmark it's already getting to be a
problem N I don't know man that's like
saying I meet people at say I only need
5 hours of sleep because I'm an evolved
creature I'm like nature everybody needs
150 minutes of Deep Sleep almost you
need eight hours and then found
a person that can live off four
hours it's like one out of a billion so
I don't think don't fight NE don't fight
the FED don't fight jeans jeans want you
to have kids second you have a kid gram
you're going to send me an ice coffee
hour just say you don't I don't even
have to say I was right cuz that's not
in your jeans you could just say maybe
you were on to something okay that's all
I want all right Fair don't try to get a
Mastery guy to say you are right that
ain't in the jeans Who says they're
wrong more between Graham and I
yeah I would say so I I will take
accountability for when I'm wrong does
apologize often
no never never there's nothing to
apologize right like if if we get into
disagreement he's not kidding that's the
crazy thing he's not kidding and he'll
say he's kidding not you to apologize
for having a different Viewpoint well
sometimes this will be like can be right
or wrong I don't think it's something
needing to an apology it's you know
what's insane I heard this thing uh who
was it I think it was Mark Manson who
says there there's a difference between
fault and responsibility I'm very much a
responsibility oriented person like
there's an issue it doesn't even matter
let's just Solve IT Graham is 100,000
fault person yes must identify in any
way possible even if it's 60% his fault
yes no it's 95% mine it's crazy is your
what's your girlfriend like what ratio
fiance fiance sorry what would you say
Jack what is she like as far far as
falter responsibility similar or I would
I don't I don't know I I I haven't
observed that so I don't want to speak
what do you think I think we're pretty
similar I believe that yeah very people
Shadow date it's crazy people really
date themselves there's a thing called
arm length study people often marry
people that have similar arm lengths H
you can Google there's a lot of this
assortative associative mating concept
of we is a dangerous thing too you got
to be It Go Cuts both ways if you marry
yourself you get some pros you get some
Downs you don't get any
offsetting so these are complic we'll
have to do third episode for this
because complicated I could go on for
hours we could just bring her on the CL
be fun that would be fun I'm glad it's
interesting yeah if I didn't have to go
to the airport I'd stay for another hour
we would we would film on clubhouse I
once was like I'm going to set a record
I think I did a 9h hour Clubhouse and it
did really well it grew it was crazy um
we would do a 9-h hour podcast without
exaggeration this is you the easiest
person we've ever filmed with hey I
would consider flying to you I would
consider doing yeah yeah so 9 Hour part
three so you think I'm the easiest yes
because you speak very well it's really
stimulating for me to I I feel like I'm
learning learning every single thing
that you say I'm Le I'm taking away
something from it I feel like you're
very insightful you have a lot of
experience in areas that we don't have
um I say you you go a mile wide and a
mile deep whereas a lot of people they
just go a mile wide or they go a mile
deep you do both you're captivating with
stories Patrick B David is the only
other person that could tell a story and
keep me hooked the entire time you're
really good with stories I needed to I
Pat was one of the first guy I had him
when he starting out on my my he wants
me to come on the podcast do it
yeah I texted him the other day he was
out of town but tell him are you guys
friends yeah we just had him on like a
couple weeks ago especially if you're
going to be in the area with fresh and
fit he's like an hour away yeah yeah he
has it would be worth it you would have
emailing me for like two years but I
just hibernated my brand so I said let
me come out of the hibernation and I'll
come on your show you would you would
really enjoy it yeah I've watched he's
growing very well he's kind of he's kind
of political now he's gotten into
politics he's really gone into the
politics right but you know I'm not that
much of a political person more business
kind
of yeah but he could talk to you about
business and human psychology but he
likes
his a good amount of his personal
development as well yeah so you can get
in there but he likes the Pol political
thing I think he does politics also goes
viral mhm it's a good way to go viral
some of the stuff I talk about you know
what it's also more conservative
Traditional Values that is what I think
his strength is yeah he's kind of going
he's a little bit been and chapiro like
yes they're in the similar yeah smart
guys they build this media I'm building
my own kind of media I call it the
Syndicate they have like Dy wire which
is Jordan Peterson I think Candace Owen
maybe's in there bench Shapiro Michael
nolles and I think Pat Patrick is doing
something similar doesn't he have a CLE
has other people but he is definitely
the face but that's kind of how Shapiro
was for a long time with daily wire till
you find your Jordan Peterson that's a
very correct Jordan Peterson is a very
captivating guy I I agree with a lot of
him but there's some things that I just
really don't agree with but he would say
the same I'm sure if I don't know if
he's ever heard me Pat's advice for me
because I gave Pat the same sort of
question I gave you his was find a
religion it doesn't have to be anything
but just find something that you could
follow and so I did one of those what is
your religion quizzes right afterwards
and I came up with Buddhism I would
disagree with that I'd agree with the
spirit but I don't think that's I don't
think that's you first off religiosity
is genetic are you a highly religious
person was your mom and dad very
religious not really no you didn't get
the religious Gene people I mean I know
people going to flip the out when
they think it's funny to me that people
agree like how you look your eyeballs
your IQ it's all genetic but no no no no
religious is totally a choice and people
go well the reason Christians you know
I'm a good Christian parent so I made
all my kids became Christians no they
inherited your genes I don't
think the religious path is yours I
think you do have a religion it's the
belief in the Mastery you're a Mastery
guy and in that I do agree with Patrick
that you must find your destiny that I
agree and you must find the gurus the
gurus and you to the extent you find
that you'll also be better at your
natural strength which is being Superior
Authority but make sure you got that
backing because like people disagree
with me I'm like on the things that I
talked about this I'm like I will come
if somebody want to debate me I'm like
let's debate these are things that I
have deep domain expertise before we go
I got one more question yeah could you
give me two really quick but some of the
most profound life lessons that you've
ever learned from Dr David bus and Joel
saltin just like one from each Ty don't
forget the power of status it's more
powerful than money that's Dr bus I I
had a whole Theory when I met Dr bus
about what women are attracted to 12
things the female algorithm calculates
and he met me after I got off stage and
said you forgot about status he's like
status beats everything height men talk
about being 66 you know the 666 rule you
make six figures 6 in dick six foot tall
unless you have status and then your
Justin Bieber ain't six foot he does
make six figures all that I don't know
about the
rest but status Joel salatan told
me I told you one of them them so I
won't say that one again well he didn't
tell me this but he showed me I
overslept I was supposed to meet him at
4:30 in the morning to help him with the
cows and I overslept so he was a man who
just proceeded to do it because it
needed to be done at 4:30 and I wasn't
there and one of the cows broke his ribs
hit him was aggressive cow and he came
with broken ribs and kick the door off
the hinges I used to sleep in a back
cabin and he's like don't ever oversleep
and that's the last time I ever
overslept so sometimes you not only need
a guru you need a boot camp you need to
kick in the ass somebody that you fear a
little bit he was a big strong guy and
that's the last time since 19 that I
ever overslept now I said three alarms
when you're tasked to do something show
up so everybody a lot of people in like
playing video games you need some mean
mofo to kick the door off the hinges and
scare the out of you and then all
of a sudden you start living out your
destiny love it well thank you so much
for coming on the podcast hi been insane
and we're so appreciative to have you
here I could easily go another three
hour we do a part three we'll do a part
three go to ty.com by the way quiz I got
the new one it'll tell you what you
should do for a living it's GNA all
right we're going to try it thank you so
oh could you really quick just look look
at this
camera